What the fuck?
What the fuck is going on in this world?
Are we really slipping away that much?
Are we really that far off kilter?
Jesus fucking Christmas
ladies and gentleman,
Chris,
is that what it's come to?
This podcast is edited for television.
This podcast is flying off the rails right
from the get go but we have sponsors.
One of them is hover and hover is
a s website domain name a company.
If you want to set up a domain name,
it's a great one to use.
And in fact I just used it myself a
couple of weeks ago for something I'll
probably never use,
but I'm crazy.
Sometimes I come up with an idea and uh,
I don't even know where
the idea came from.
It might have come from marijuana,
it might really be marijuana's
idea and I borrowed it,
but I registered a domain and I did it
through hover.com and it was super quick
and easy.
If you go to hover.com
forward slash Rogen,
you can get 10% off of your domain name.
Registrations.
Hover is owned by the same
people that don't Tang.
And what we like about them,
the same things that we like about tank,
they're trying to provide a service
without ripping people off that everybody
could use.
Indeed.
And you know,
there's the business is not a bad thing.
We just always associate businesses
with being a bunch of greedy cunts.
And that's why people think of
corporations and think of businesses.
We kind of all categorize them together.
Are you selling me something?
Oh well then you must be an asshole.
You know,
you must have this predatory mindset of
just trying to squeeze as much money out
of me as possible.
That's not how Harvard deals with it.
Um,
and the way they do deal with it,
they just tried to give you a good
service and give it to you at a reasonable
price and include things a lot
of people make you pay for it.
Like who is privacy?
So,
uh,
go and check him out because her awesome.
Go to hover.com forward slash Rogen and
get yourself 10% off any of your domain
name registrations.
We are also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com and uh,
if you've listened to the show
over the past couple of months,
you've listened to about all the different
shit that Ana is added into its store
for a fitness including these,
uh,
steel clubs and steel maces
and kettlebells and a saw,
it appears.
Look,
looks like a soft chin up bar.
Decapitate the victims know that that
sits on your fucking the door and allows
you to do chin ups on the,
yeah,
it's easy to use it.
It latches like it,
it rests on your,
uh,
the top of your door.
So you can do chin ups in your house and
there's the rope to strangle yourself.
That's triangle on anybody.
You shouldn't do that.
I don't think people,
I bet most people that get busted or
die of auto erotic expatiation they were
really getting set up.
Somebody tried to set them up to make
them look as foolish as possible.
Oh,
look at him and his Dick in his hand.
I know a lot of girls that would like to
be choked the fuck when you're fucking
them.
That's true.
But I think that's sort of a weird
freaky domination thing as well.
I think,
uh,
the girls who want you to choke him there,
they also want you to fuck up my gear.
Some Mongol that just came over the top
of the hill and it hasn't seen a woman
in six months.
Those are crazy bitches.
Yeah.
But I don't know.
I've never jerked off in the Necktie,
like hanging off the headboard.
It might be awesome first.
I'm not going to try with a battle rope.
It's definitely,
yeah,
that's too thick.
It's very rough to,
it wouldn't be nice for your skin,
you know,
then you have a collar shirt on
it and you'd be irritated all day.
My point is,
um,
all the stuff that we're selling,
one of the most important things that
I could ever tell you is if you want to
use any of this exercise equipment,
um,
get yourself a trainer and get someone,
I don't know how much they
cost 50 bucks or whatever.
Get somebody who understands kettlebells
and just not to take you through a
workout and necessarily,
but just teach you the correct
fundamentals of how to use the,
the,
the weights properly,
how to lift without hurting yourself.
And you don't have to use a lot of weight.
One of the beautiful things about
kettlebells as you're going to get amazing
workout from a 35 pound kettle bell,
there's a video that we sell
called the extreme kettlebell DVD.
Um,
it's,
I use a 35 pound kettle bell for that
thing and he kicks my ass every time.
45 minutes in,
I'm ready to throw up.
I mean it's,
it's really hard to do.
It's really hard.
You got to have fucking to be
hard to use a 35 pound weight.
You Pussy.
Just trust me cause you're
using your whole body.
You'd be amazed at how much your own
body if you have to just moving your body
around doing body weight squats,
how difficult that is to do.
I do 200 bodyweight Hindus,
Hindus squats.
It's really hard to do when you,
by the time you get to 200,
you fucking legs are shaking and knock in,
you're barely getting
through those last 50.
Um,
it's,
it's not,
you don't necessarily have to always
lift heavy weights or do just the
traditional exercises that you've seen,
you know,
bench press and curls and stuff like that.
You know,
those,
they serve their purpose.
But the reality is if you want exercises
that help you in athletics or help you
with functional strength,
um,
the,
the best ones are the ones that
incorporate your whole body.
And so that's where the steel clubs come
in and steal naces and that's where the
like medicine balls and stuff like that,
there's a lot of different workouts.
If you're interested
in any of these things,
once you learn how to do
the technique properly,
there's a lot of different workouts that
you can get online on Youtube for free.
It's like super easy to find.
I have a question,
Joe.
I don't have doctor laser.
Maybe could answer this or not,
but uh,
I'm not sure if he's real.
That's fine.
The spider that we showed yesterday,
but that was growing the horns.
It's actually a fungus virus from
the courthouse steps mushrooms,
which is one of the main
ingredients to shroom sport.
So
what's that all about?
Like,
am I going to get us to have horns?
Cordyceps mushrooms is
also the mushroom that,
um,
it,
it makes those ants zombies.
You know that,
uh,
you know that.
Yeah.
This is a crazy mushroom.
It's not any,
not only does it make the answers zombies,
but it also will be,
it will grow inside of the dead
ant take over the antibody,
grow inside the den.
And the other answer
recognize it's a threat.
So they take it out of town.
They literally take the ants body and
walk miles away from where their ant hill
is.
Because if they leave the ant there,
if the ant is sick with this mushroom,
if he's infected,
the amp will climb to the top of the,
the highest leaf.
It could fine.
And then it explodes.
And so this is how the army,
right?
This is how you control the army.
And he's just trying to get people
endurance when they're doing crossfit.
Sorry.
You do not have to worry about it.
This is a totally different part or
a strain of the quarter sub smasher,
right?
It doesn't have the Zombie properties.
Does it have hints of it?
Like a hint of mint?
It just a little kid,
a little assets,
essence of Zombie.
Could you imagine if the Zombie apocalypse
lips was all started by
a fitness supplement?
Well,
mushrooms are fucked up,
man.
When you think about it,
some of them get you high as fuck.
Some of them will kill you immediately.
Some of them will give you endurance.
Some of them are great
for your immune system.
You're turning into a dark day,
but you're controlling.
You're going to have a galactic army.
I think Darth Vader just use the forest,
so I don't think he
had mushrooms involved.
Intimidation that mushrooms,
you know,
Terence Mckenna believed that mushrooms
were an alien species for one good
reason.
The four Fox,
four [inaudible] and
dimethyltryptamine than this.
The scientific designation of it and it's
the only is the only plant with a four
and the phosphorous position and the
known on earth and he believed that it's
possible that spores
could survive in a vacuum.
We like pants.
Yeah,
that's definitely true.
If that's true,
it's real possible.
If panspermia is real and amino
acids and building blocks of life,
I've actually come here.
Even possibly living things
were spores from other planets.
Why wouldn't some of have
been magic mushrooms son?
Dude,
you would
check the genes for,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
yeah.
Well that's why.
I mean,
how do we know though if
Panspermia we checked the jeans,
I mean if everything
comes from other planets,
all kinds of common shit or that random
coincidence that something that comes
from space is as related to us
as we are to like our plants.
Like that would be odd.
It would be,
unless life was pretty uniform.
Yeah,
that's true.
All over the galaxy.
There's like coincidental little
parts of the DNA and either way,
folks,
you don't have to worry about that.
We had honor and not trying to get you
to grow elk horns out of the end of your
spider legs
turned into Tron,
that guy super.
He's got a horns coming out of him.
I don't hate on superhuman dudes.
He's an extra man like neon light,
glowy radio.com you fucks use a code name,
Rogan and save 10% off
any and all supplements.
All right,
my pal,
J D is here.
We know this fucker a long time and uh,
we're fitting to get busy.
Hit The music prime.
Okay,
well,
good experience.
I met this young man
when he was a,
what do you,
what would you like 17
or something like that?
1717.
During the first Houston circle jerk of,
was that pre 2001?
Was that precepting oh two or something?
Was it the Houston circle jerk was out to,
um,
he was,
uh,
you were like 17 back then
and a high school student.
Right now you're like an actual physicist.
And uh,
his name on my message board,
it's WIC.
And this is,
this sounds like the,
the dorkiest beginning of a podcast ever.
But,
um,
my message boards is a very strange place.
It's a very odd community and I've tried
to keep it as positive and healthy as
possible,
but there's always going to be a certain
amount of constant creeps and there's
always going to be a certain amount of
obsessed people and there's always going
to be a certain amount of Weirdos.
But there's also a lot
of cool people there too.
It's a,
an interesting place and a place where
some pretty intense stuff gets discussed
by some really intelligent people.
Definitely.
I learned so much,
especially in my early years of like being
on the board and like 2001 when there
was barely anybody on
the internet already,
but they had all these
smart people on your board,
like twice my age,
having conversations about shit
that I had never heard in my life.
Yeah.
And I don't know how it happened either.
So the way it happened is very strange.
It's like that message board
almost like wanted to be born.
I don't even remember how I got on it.
Well,
I don't remember how I got out.
I had a free [inaudible]
easy board before that.
Like there was a whole
board before the board,
you were on the easy board,
right?
Briefly,
like rally a couple of weeks or something.
It was,
it was just html,
basic comments,
thread shit.
Yeah,
it was sue.
I wouldn't,
yeah,
I would need to go back
and find that thing.
But then it went to this like a different
format where it sort of just got
spread around and I
don't know what happened.
It just,
all these strange,
odd people just started showing up like
Voodoo chicken who's been on forever.
It was like,
yeah,
he was a big inspiration
in my early years.
And he's a good friend now.
I mean,
uh,
I hang out with them every
time I go to Seattle and moot.
And,
uh,
you know,
so many of these other people that we've
met off the angry Amadeus and all these
different folks that
we've met from the board.
And,
uh,
it just,
it's,
uh,
I know,
you know,
when I,
when I say I don't know how it started,
I really don't.
And even though it's my board,
you know,
it has my name on it,
I keep it up and everything like that.
I guess I'm sorta responsible
somewhat to the tone,
the guiding force.
Like I don't know if you like before you,
you instituted the porn role where you
had to postpone within 10 posts or you
were the band.
I don't think like it was already in a,
uh,
an agreed upon.
Yeah.
People would just get shit
that was crescent wrenches.
I believe it was his idea.
I can't,
you know,
we're,
we're talking about a message
board that was started in 1998.
That's when my message board was started.
Before Facebook,
before Google for everything
before I can go for my space.
Yeah.
It was before all that shit.
And um,
when did,
when it was started,
we would get all these annoying people
and then everyone was assuming everyone
was sure that fear factor
was going to kill it.
This is going to be the 10th of the board.
His board is going to suck now.
But that's when we
instituted the porn rule.
It was like right around then.
It was like right around
the fear of failure.
We're scared of him.
We were scared of the wave of incoming
fear factor fans and the porn rule was
you had to prove that you weren't
a tight ass by by putting porn,
some kind of porn during your first
10 to be deemed acceptable too.
It's not just like a tiny
little thumbnail of some chicks,
tits.
No.
So dudes would completely
overdo it where their first,
this is my first offering and it would
just be Jeff Cox and miles and common
phases and fucking gang bangs and then
embed videos and then people would just
go,
well done sir.
Well done.
Welcome aboard.
You know,
one day I went and I looked at my board
and it was just the most ridiculous
fucking resource of porn on
the Internet and I'm like,
what happened here?
And a lot of people like it worked.
They weren't allowed at work to use my
board because you would open a thread and
just randomly there'd be Cox.
Any thread could be the least appropriate.
It would be to put point in that thread.
The more likely it would be that there
would be pointing pointed that thread and
still is.
I mean at any point in
time you go to that board,
you open a thread,
someone's talking to cock
and no one takes that out.
And you know if my manager
found out about that,
if they actually went in
there and started like going,
do you know that there was pornography
all throughout your message board?
The Tom,
Tom,
he would,
he would get all Joe Friday on me.
I remember one of my favorite points that,
I mean before video,
so it was just like pictures and a lot
of gay porn cause it's hilarious straight
people and it was one,
it was just a a black dude with like a
really small Coty and it was just coated
in calm.
It was just a little come
sash and that just for months.
That might've been my favorite
thing to just see similar posts.
The Internet to me will always be
represented by that one photo of that guy
spreading his asshole
apart with his fingers.
But not him.
It's a different,
it's like a similar,
it might not be gutsy,
but it's a,
it's a guy doing that and they Photoshop
the kid's face and the kid's like,
eyes are open and his
mouth is always like,
what the fuck?
And right underneath that it says,
welcome to the Internet.
That will always be the internet.
To me,
when I think of the Internet,
I think of that,
this fucking the Internet.
I think of the worst things in the world.
Goatee or,
or Dick Nipples,
shedding technicals.
Well,
we don't even realize that when,
well I guess you don't realize it because
you sort of grew up with the Internet,
but when I was a kid,
you'd never got to see any of the
things that people are so conditioned to
seeing today as far as like dead people.
And I mean,
I remember when faces of death came out,
it was the craziest set.
A friend that had a v Vcrs,
VHS tape,
right?
Whatever.
There's a called the looking
at a dead person was like,
oh my God,
it's a dead body.
Like they're showing
dead bodies on a video.
By the time you're 16 in America,
how many fucking dead bodies
have you seen on the Internet?
How many people sent you fucked up
images of gory things that have happened?
Car accidents and wolf
attacks and you know,
thought fuck man.
On just like,
right.
Like I got on the Internet when I was 13,
so like 98.
So like I,
and I was in Kansas or I lived in Kansas.
So like we're a little
behind the times anyway.
Do you remember that first video of that?
Um,
the reporter was the reporter or a
journalist that was killed during the
beginning of the Iraq war.
Daniel something or another.
But they cut his head off with a knife
and they showed his head like they
held his head up and you're like,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
Want to spread the fuck all over the,
yeah.
That might've been the first,
the first be heading on the Internet.
I think it,
well,
I don't think it was just
the biggest headache.
There was the biggest cause it was a,
you know,
it was a big deal that this guy was an
American who was kidnapped and murdered.
But the,
the photo,
um,
there was,
or there was a video rather a shorter
video that was on an Internet of a
Russian,
uh,
soldiers stabbing a guy in the neck,
like holding the guy down with his
boot and stabbing them in the neck.
And that was the first
one that I had ever seen.
But by now those,
there's this,
how many of those are out there?
How many of those a Mexican drug
lord ones are there with chainsaws?
Shit.
Now though,
like nowadays,
like I had like a few years where I
just saw every horrible thing that could
happen and now I just,
it like,
you know,
it fucks you up a little bit.
It definitely does.
Do you feel like that's
like how like you're,
you know,
in,
in Holland where pot is everywhere
and hookers are everywhere,
they have the lowest levels of aids,
infection or HIV infection
in all of Europe.
They also have the lowest
numbers of heroin addiction.
And I think,
you know,
when we had boss root non from Holland
he was talking about like they don't have
a drinking age like you,
like it'd be 12 and have a beer
and that because of that we,
you know,
we're weird if you tell us we're
not supposed to do something,
we want to do it in really
indulgent as a culture,
as over cheese.
But as a species I think the human animal
when you tell us not to do something
like fuck you.
I mean that's how it is with kids.
I mean I you see it so clearly
with children when you're
raising a little babies
and you see them from the get go,
like from the womb boom,
boom.
When you see like cause
and effect with them.
It's so fascinating that we are hardwired
to not want to do what other people
tell us to do.
So as soon as someone comes
along and says don't drink,
don't smoke,
don't do this,
don't do that.
Those are the things you want to do.
And because of the fact that you
never had anybody telling you,
hey,
don't watch beheadings online because
your parents probably had no idea the
headings online.
If you were a normal person in the 1990s
and you were out there working a job,
you know you didn't have time to
come home and watch beheadings,
you know you didn't,
you didn't know what the fuck your kid
was doing on style project dot Carr to
find hard to find some time.
But you're a good example of a guy who
grew up during the part of the Internet.
Like you can't the first wave before
anybody understood what was happening,
you know,
and now everybody's like,
they're trying to lock it down and price
regulation and tried to figure things
out and just like authority figures
didn't know where we're going on.
Nobody didn't know.
But like it was still,
it was still something nerds did.
It was going on the Internet,
but you got an email
address like why I but and,
and if you had a website back then,
if you,
if you did anything,
like if anything got like viral in
any sort of a way in a bunch of people
downloaded it,
you would be crushed with a bill that
would fucking bankrupt your whole family.
Yeah,
I would,
I would put out like one
blog and someone would read,
would,
you know,
we're re posted somewhere on some famous
website and then all of a sudden your
bandwidth costs would be fucking insane.
Like thousands and thousands
of dollars a month,
hundreds of megs
downloaded from their site.
What's wrong with hundreds of megs?
Could you see that fit photo that someone
had on Twitter the other day of the
thing being loaded onto it?
You knew it was funny
about the message board.
Like you said,
the rules that you used to have where
you had to post 10 photos before you post
it,
but also the,
the,
there was a website that everyone passed
around called black people loves us.
So whenever,
whenever somebody posted something
that everyone has already seen or it's
already been posted before,
everyone would just be like,
black people loves you or black people
loves pie or whatever the thing is,
it would be black.
You bill loves us and then it became BP.
Yeah.
It got so,
so stay so natural for us because
the black people loves us.
Website was so silly.
It was just a bunch of
white people that were,
you know,
photos of black people looking
ridiculously uncomfortable
and it hasn't been
updated since it was made
maybe 2003 or something like,
well we price obviously
bringing it up a parody site.
Yeah,
it's going down.
Right.
For sure.
But that become,
it became a,
an infraction on our message.
If you,
uh,
if you post something too many times
when it's already obviously old,
it becomes black peopled.
Yeah.
It seems so racist,
but it's not at all unless you let her
side of a black person once hosting.
It's not what it is.
If you,
you need,
it's a website.
It's in reference to a website.
It's not in reference to black people.
It's,
this is the day,
you know,
it's uh,
I feel like the,
one of the weird things that's
happened because of the Internet,
I feel like people are more sensitive
than ever and more quick to be outraged
than ever.
It seems like even though there's so
much crazy shit that you could say at any
point in time,
and it should give us a,
a sort of a broader perspective on things.
I feel like people are more easily outrage
or at least they'll see it as a green
light to plot out.
It's like you can be proud of,
of identifying victim hood.
Yes.
Like you don't even have to be the victim.
You can just,
you can just,
yeah.
You're going to hurt somebody's feelings.
Yeah.
You have clout from that.
Oh,
this is the transgender thing.
He's we bringing that up.
All right.
This is the second biggest story on TMZ,
right?
Yeah.
People are upset.
Well,
96% of the people on
fucking TMZ agree with me.
I typed him.
Great Point.
I've never seen that far of a sweat.
Usually.
Usually it's like 42% versus you know,
7% are regarding video
contains explicit language.
While the video was me and
David Lee Roth actually getting,
talking about,
don't,
don't click on it.
We don't need to.
I'll explain exactly what I said.
I'm fully in favor of someone
being a transgender person.
I feel like you should be able to do
whatever you want to do with your body.
I'm covered in tattoos.
Who,
what?
You know,
maybe for some people that might be more
horrific than chopping your dick off.
You know,
I don't know.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want you to do anything
you don't want to do and a,
I wouldn't want to stop you from
doing something you truly want to do.
I don't know how your mind works.
I Dunno how your body works.
I don't know what's in your soul.
I don't know if you,
you,
you know you have all
whatever makes you happy.
It's what I'm trying to say.
My issue is the mechanical advantage that
a female has over a man and people are
saying,
do research out of a
transgender woman or yeah,
male rather has over a few wall.
Um,
the mechanical advantage
of male has over a female.
The people are like
tweeting means saying like,
do some research.
It's been proven that when a woman takes
hormones or bone density decreases and
decreases,
doesn't even out.
It just doesn't,
that's nonsense.
See that?
That's not a woman's hand.
Okay,
that's,
that's way too big to be a woman's hand.
And if I chop my dick off,
I would still have that.
And that's a big one.
The Tan,
very easily
mechanical advantages and
the width of the shoulders,
the,
that doesn't go away.
There's mechanical advantages in the
strength of the jaw that the way it's
built,
you can absorb more punches.
There's even 135 pound
woman who's in really fit,
strong,
like healthy shape.
She's not as strong as 135
pound man who's in fit,
strong,
healthy shape.
We're just built different.
The,
the advantages will diminish
someone with hormone treatment.
And,
uh,
a man who goes through the transgender
operation will certainly become more like
a woman.
But at the end of the day,
he has an x,
y chromosome that,
and that's reality.
It's not double x.
That's not a woman.
That's a man.
And if you're happier that way,
Dan is fine.
If you're a transgender though,
you're not a male.
I don't that it's
driving me fucking crazy.
The idea that you're hurting people's
feelings by saying the exact correct
scientific distinct term
for what the fuck they are,
which I don't think you're hurting a
lot of transient transgendered people's
feelings directly.
I'm sure.
Cause they're mad at me on Twitter.
People are calling me a pig there.
Call me and asymptotically
transgendered people specifically.
And specifically because I
said that it's not a woman.
They're like a transgender
woman is a woman.
No,
you want to feel like you're a woman
and that's all good in the hood.
But that's bullshit.
That's like,
it's just where
it's just like we're,
we're,
we're behind the times where like
we get to make new kinds of people.
Like,
I think it's awesome that we
can have any kind of that what,
this is so crude,
it's something new.
It's not,
not that they shouldn't
be called women heard,
right.
It's like new.
It is going to take the whole culture a
little getting used to and I feel like
it's just the beginning and one day we'll
look back on this and mock it the way
we look at horrible operations
that they used to do.
Remember when they used to do hair
plugs where they have like doll hair,
a circular,
they would take a circular plug.
I have a friend who has
them all over his head.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's very unfortunate because it
grows like 30 hairs in one tweet.
Just patch.
Even like weeds,
like a bamboo forest.
It doesn't make any sense.
Can you get it taken out or anything?
Yeah,
he could.
That's the only way.
That's the only thing you can do.
You can actually get the,
the thing taken out,
but my point is that's
an ancient operation.
They don't do it that way now.
Really?
That's like really old.
You know?
It's really old,
but that's how we're going to look at
transgender operations in the future.
There's not gonna be like a
physical change with a scalpel.
They're going to be able
to change your genetically.
They're going to be able to
actually make you a woman.
You will actually put that,
and by the way,
you might be able to try it out and say,
you know what?
This sucks.
Can I get my Dick back?
Boom.
And they turned you back into a man again.
I mean,
I think for the most part we like there.
There's clearly neurological differences
and somebody that thinks they're a
woman like that,
it's more similar to a woman.
I don't think you can generalize
because I don't think it's uniform.
I don't think one
person's feeling of that.
I feel like I'm a woman is
the same as another person's.
I just don't think how that,
I don't see how that can be possible.
This is a fucking green light,
green light time to cut off my dick.
You know?
It's like,
you know,
well,
we've looked at your brain.
The green light switch is
off.
We doubt your intentions.
What nightclub?
They take this photo I when you too.
Or is this way?
Whoa.
We were dancing.
You know I don't mind
dancing with trainees.
That's actually Photoshop.
That's not,
that's real.
We were right there together.
They were dancing.
Just getting down.
Look at her dancing hands.
That's the Shittier Photoshop and the
one with Lee Harvey Oswald holding a gun.
Like tone your face or at least match it.
Yeah.
No,
they didn't want to
make it look realistic.
People halfass a Photoshop like clearly
you can mount up sale chair on that
layer.
This is tmz.com this is a real website.
People go here.
Shitty this photo real website.
Here's the biggest
issue with this whole training thing.
That woman,
whatever you want to call her.
A transgender woman fought three women
without letting them know she used to be
a man and beat the fuck out of them.
Knock them all out brutally quickly
and cause damage to their brain.
Jesus.
Yeah.
That's a man.
A man beat the fuck out of some
women has present anything to it yet.
No.
You know what,
man,
look if there's any confusion about
me in the gay community whatsoever.
It's because of things I've said,
but it's,
I can see how they would be confused.
It's also how I look.
It's also what I do
do.
I'm a,
I'm a not just a standup comedian,
which are,
we were always known
for being rude cause we,
that's part of what's the art of
standup comedy is saying Rude Shit.
Sometimes I enjoy people
that say root shit.
I think it's funny and it's an art form.
Just like,
I like Johnny Cash singing
about shooting men in Reno,
but I don't think he really
did shoot a man in Reno.
Okay.
Robert Johnson singing,
chasing is women around with a gun cause
she's got a smaller gun then he does.
He might have actually done that though.
Robert Johnson was living the life.
It's still good for him.
But my point is,
uh,
and you know,
their connection to the
cage fighting and all that,
but I am absolutely 100%
not homophobic at all.
I have gay friends,
I have lesbian friends.
I do not.
Speaking of the board,
do you remember that time
when you and Crypto or you,
you painted your,
your fingernail for one of
the members of the board?
[inaudible] yeah.
Then you guys had a
little fake kissy photo.
If that's true,
Joe,
then why did you,
where's my painting?
My words,
my gay drawing.
I took that down.
It was offensive.
Got bored with it.
Man.
It's hard to look at behind me.
Cartoon of Cock behind you.
I don't care what anybody does.
I really don't.
I'm not,
I'm not a homophobic person at all.
You know?
And that's what something that homophobic.
So I always say every racist,
I'm not racist.
I have a black friend,
but I,
I really,
I grew up in San Francisco from the
age seven to 11 and I grew up in a gay
neighborhood and my next door neighbors
were gay and they used to get naked with
my aunt and smoke pot and play the bow,
the Bongo drums together.
It was so weird,
was like
weird at the time.
Like you're like,
this isn't what people use
get naked.
They didn't show me the Kochs or anything.
My,
my aunt didn't show me
her naked body either,
but they let,
she let me know what they did.
Like she thought it was
awesome because she was like,
at the time she was probably like 18,
something like that.
She was pretty young and when
she was staying with us and um,
you know,
she would go next door and smoke weed
with the gay guys and play Bongos.
I just thought,
what the fuck.
So like my whole introduction to gay
people came really early and it was in San
Francisco where it was really accepted.
San Francisco was a great place for me
to grow up when I was a small boy between
like seven and 11.
Well,
it was a pretty sweet
time from San Francisco.
Yeah,
it was post Vietnam war,
you know,
everybody had sort of
relaxed a little bit and,
but the gang thing and the racism thing,
San Francisco is remarkably
unraced remarkably.
And I didn't realize it myself
until I moved to Florida.
When I moved to Florida.
Um,
I was in school and I asked,
I had came home to ask
my mom what a nigger met.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
I didn't,
and she was mad at me.
She's like,
you know what it means?
I'm like,
I don't know what it means.
What does it mean?
And she said it's a derogatory term for
a black person and I want what I was
like,
wow.
Cause a bunch of kids in my class,
we're calling somebody that
I didn't know what it meant.
So I had to go home and ask my mother.
It's because between seven and 11,
when I lived in San Francisco,
I didn't hear that.
I didn't hear it in school.
I was in a normal public
school mixed with black kids,
white kids,
Asian kids.
I never heard that word.
See,
I kind of headed different,
I just grew up around a lot
of really nice white people.
So it just didn't come up.
Like I,
there were a couple of
black kids in my school and,
but I didn't,
I didn't really like pick up on that,
that they were different or anything.
But it wasn't until I was like 10 or 11
that I realized that the reason there
would be Annie,
any animosity between white and
black people was because of slavery,
because that when I was a kid,
I was just like,
Oh,
Europeans took Africans to America to be,
to make them slaves and it like the
black white thing didn't occur to me.
I just knew Africans were brought over
here and it didn't realize that they
came,
like I knew they were darker or whatever,
but it hadn't occurred to me that
like that was a racial thing.
It was just like,
oh,
Africans were enslaved.
Not necessarily black people
where,
where did you grow up?
You grew up in Kentucky,
Kansas,
Kansas.
You might as well,
we can talk.
It's like,
Whoa,
what?
What's all those flatter?
It was realizes that I would never go.
It's really nice.
Kansas is really nice.
They're very polite people.
They're very polite people,
but not a lot of shit goes on,
right?
No,
nothing that I know of.
Barbecue Barbecue's great
barbecue and drinking,
right?
Occasional mechanical bowl.
Yeah.
About that.
I mean,
you know,
it was,
it was the first free state or that was,
that chose to be a free state.
Really.
Kansas was when,
when states started getting the choice
between being a slave or free state.
But
would you ever go back there?
What if the Zombie apocalypse happened?
Then you had a fucking farm
where he could hold out.
It'd be pretty good.
I mean,
it's super flat.
Chris Hilton.
No.
What does it say?
Condos?
Do you sell condos?
Do you,
what does it say?
I just kidding it.
Does that,
is that like comes supposedly on my face.
Paris Hilton.
Does he like just puts a couple of drops?
I Dunno.
I like for his help.
I hope it doesn't get mad at me for this.
I hope nobody gets mad at me for this
cause I'm not telling anybody what to do
other than men shouldn't
be able to beat women up.
You're the best producer ever,
Brian.
It's probably as good as it gets.
I haven't looked around for that reason.
He's a gem.
Um,
so anyway,
that was just me explaining
my position on gay people.
I don't give a fuck.
I want everybody to be happy and um,
this has nothing to do with that.
To me it has to do with the mechanical
advantages of being in a male frame.
And if you want to
consider yourself a woman,
that's cool.
I think someday we're going
to be able to fix anything.
I think if you lose your leg,
they'll be able to grow your new one.
If you decide to be a woman,
they'll be able to do that.
If you look at what we can do now,
we're printing off skull parts,
hearts and livers and shit.
Crazy.
Really creating human bladders,
you know that that can be
surgically implanted in people.
There's a lot of nutty,
nutty shit that's going on and it's really
going to start wrecking shop on what
it means to be a person.
Well,
you know,
someone said,
could you ever see what,
what's going to go on in a year from now?
Well,
no,
not really anymore.
It used to be,
yeah,
it used to be like in 1978
the most between 1978 1979.
What's going to happen was,
you know,
maybe someone would
come up with a new car,
you know,
there might be a fucking better
eight track that was invented.
I mean that was,
it wasn't a lot of crazy shit going on,
but every day there's some new insane
invention or discovery or proclamation
that makes you go,
what the fuck is going to
happen a year from now?
All these different like fields have
been like merging together and computer
scientists contributing to
neuroscience and everything else.
Everybody's helping each other and they've
all been developing like really well
as their own fields.
And there's this weird synergies
like Kurt's while going to Google,
you know,
like he works for Google now.
The Guy who wants the technological
singularity to include you downloading
yourself into a fucking computer,
just started working at sky net.
I mean,
nobody's even pick these dudes are
fucking all planning the takeover.
And then they brought in Lex Luther,
he's sitting there eating
a hundred pills with lunch,
trying to stay alive
for an extra five years.
So I love that shit.
Yeah,
I love Google.
I,
you know,
I keep thinking about how like whatever
information they end up being forced to
share with the government or something
like how much information if they given
us,
like I got here on Google maps,
like half the stuff I like.
Everything I look up is on good.
They give me information
for free all the time.
Right.
So if they want some mind
that's I'm okay with that.
Well,
honestly I think we're in a state where
the ability of the average person is
closing in so fast on the ability of the
government that they're going to merge
sort of like Fahrenheit and Celsius
when they hit 40 below zero,
the same temperature.
I think technology is going to the,
the,
the boundary breaking
qualities of technology and
the ability to connect people
is going to eventually hit a critical
point where it's not gonna matter if you
work for the government.
It's like I am going to
be able to read your mind.
I'm not going to need to go to the
database that they're building in Utah.
I'm going to be able to access
information everywhere all the time.
There's going to get to that point and
you could see like that it's getting away
even from the government itself,
because look at like what happened?
Well,
look at what the CIA guy,
what the fuck's his name?
That that got busted with a the
email exchange with the mistress.
Oh,
the fuck is his name.
The big guy.
The Big Patraeus.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Betray us.
That's to me,
when the number one spook the CIA,
the number one spa intelligence
blasted because the FBI looks into him.
I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ.
They're,
they're,
they're cannibalizing themselves.
The government themselves
as cannibalize themselves.
They don't know what they're doing anymore
than anybody else does in this brave
new world is that all this
technology and everything,
everybody there,
especially the ones that
are holding onto power,
they're in a panic.
Yeah,
and in doing something like that,
I think they showed their pants.
I think they dropped their
pants and they're idiots.
Yeah,
absolutely.
First of all,
because I never knew that the
CIA and the FBI didn't get along.
Did you know that?
I kind of heard things,
but I don't know if it was just like an
x files thing that's gotta be turned off
TV.
I don't know.
I don't really know.
That's the dumbest fucking Shit
I've ever heard in my life.
You concert supposed to be Americans,
you know,
and anybody who would dare call someone
like me unpatriotic because I think that
the government feel mostly with idiots
and make terrible decisions based on
money.
You're,
what are you doing?
The FBI and the CIA don't like each other.
Well you fucks have a softball
game and work that out.
Jesus Christ.
Your whole summary from each other
because you don't want this person to move
ahead with that person to get a job in
the next administration that maybe you
think you could've gotten there
competing with each other over.
What the fuck?
It's just like office politics or like,
or like a,
you know,
a hunting lodge or something.
Just competing with some
other hunting lodge.
Like it's just most ducks and then a guy
like Dick Cheney shoots his friend in
the face.
That's what that Shit's from.
Be a little more an alcohol.
How,
how drunk was Dick Cheney?
And he shot his friend
in the face probably.
Fuck,
we got really smooth pacemaker
thing he's got going on.
He's got a heart.
But he had a,
he had a pacemaker that was so fucking
strange that it didn't leave him with a
heartbeat as smooth.
It didn't have a heartbeat.
It was just a constant flow of blood.
That's gotta be in the Bible,
right?
The one that,
yes,
he take you out the heart of another
and implanted in this tissue.
I just do a joke about how,
uh,
Dick Cheney had one extra secret service
agent that came with them everywhere
and the dude was only unhealthy food
and they made them jog every day.
And he's like,
what the fuck?
Why can't I have a burger shut up,
run.
And then they followed him everywhere.
He went with a,
a giant cooler filled with ice.
And then the moment Dick Cheney drops,
they got to fucking cut
that kind of like a fish,
pull out his ticker and stuffed it in
that old man's cavity that I wouldn't,
I wouldn't doubt it.
You know,
people would but see soon,
just like you were saying,
eventually we will all have a cooler
full of extra Oregon's just in case.
Well I think it's going to
be even crazier than that.
And they're going to be able to inject
something into your body and you're just
to agree grow stem cells or the one you
have all of a sudden starts functioning
like really awesome.
You know,
40 beats per minute.
I'm more excited about not like
fixing stuff but making stuff better.
Like I want,
I want octopus size or something.
I want something powerful.
Octopus eyes are very similar to humanize.
And one of the weirdest things
about octopus is that w we,
we branched off from there evolutionary
line like hundreds of millions of years.
13 I think the last I saw it was like 13
to 40 times independently and they all
use the same crystals and molecules to
make the lenses and everything else cause
they,
cause they work the same for everybody.
That's why I was interested
in what we were talking about,
um,
during the commercial
part about Panspermia,
about the idea of spores and different
things coming from other planets and seed
and life on earth.
If that really did happen,
how strange would it be of life
really is just sort like this,
this is,
this is the kind of thing,
this is life.
This is how it grows.
I think when we do find some other life,
it will look really similar.
Well,
could we find here like,
look,
if you look at like placental and uh,
uh,
marsupial mammals,
like they split or like from an early
point and yet you have like placental deer
and marsupial deal deer and they have
all these like kind of really similar
animals because it works the same.
So like that's,
that's the conclusion you would nature
comes to for like some sort of projects.
So why wouldn't that work elsewhere?
Right.
And think about what we know has
existed and what currently exists.
Think about the immense variety.
Like I was playing with my daughter
today at her school had this,
they have a big bucket of dinosaurs,
dinosaur like toys,
you know,
kids to play with.
And uh,
you know,
she's asked me,
well,
what's this one called with that.
So we're going over the,
all the little dinosaurs and I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
how many of these fucking
things were there?
And I'm crazy.
They,
this giant ass flying lizard and it's
huge fucking thing with a monster face.
And you know,
you're looking at all these different
things like just the variety of them is so
alien.
Yeah.
They were around for like a
hundred some million years.
Yeah.
And they had all kinds of times,
shit that's still here.
Elephants and crocodiles and people like
just the wide variety that exists right
now,
but yet,
so similar carbon based life form
a lot of different variables.
Some of them,
you know,
cold blooded,
some warm blooded,
some [inaudible] work.
And so they keep doing it.
Yeah.
It's just a wonder if like you said,
like it all,
it needs similar,
but you know,
but pretty different conditions I think.
I think we'll,
we'll,
I mean we'll definitely
find plants another planet,
right?
Because chlorophyll is somewhat easy to
make and absorbing light from the sun is
a really smart thing to do.
I don't even have to be
the way to do it though.
I mean we've shown in this
world that in the vents,
the volcanic vents,
bottom of the oceans where
no light reaches at all,
they've all,
all life needs apparently his energy,
we used to think it needed light
but all life needs is some sources.
As long as there is light,
there'll be ones taking advantage of it.
Yeah.
If there is light and if they're taking
advantage of something like sunlight,
they're going to do really,
really well and the only life that
competes with them is going to be going
underground to thermal
events and shit like that.
Like it.
If it works really well,
then they'll keep doing it right in the,
the,
the other issue is that the life,
unless it comes up with some
other way to manufacture things,
it's not going to the,
the life that lives in the bottom of the
ocean near those events is not going to
have the same ability to progress is
something that there's no stimulation to
change.
They say that about the ocean,
that there's,
there's less diversity in the species
down there because there's less like a
need for change.
Like up here we have all this geographic
mountains and deserts and forests and
lakes and all this other shit.
And down there you just have
like up and down basically.
And then when you get down
to the surface Godzilla,
oh yeah,
that's right.
You got to compete with that motherfucker.
Oh,
you got to go a little shirt on.
What are the odds?
Crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
from radiation and from its,
it was forced to change from Fukushima,
well I think it was
Gonzolo was nuclear bombs,
but I'm sure the Japanese is probably
coming up with some new monster movies
now.
Right.
Cause based on Fukushima.
Oh,
I bet.
I guess so you'd have to human gods,
Philippine.
But I bet a lot of people probably
upset that Godzilla wasn't real.
Nothing has happened like that.
Like no,
there's no,
see,
I told you a moment.
Well yeah,
that and,
and Bruce Banner getting irradiated
and Spiderman getting bitten by an
irradiated fucking spider.
Like that makes any sense.
Yes.
Unfortunately radiation
doesn't really seem to do that.
I felt it was very weak that the new
Spiderman had a new way he got bid.
Oh yeah.
You didn't see that?
No.
Why would I just see it bro
and new Spiderman movie.
How dare you
so
rude out.
Tobey Maguire's dancing from Spiderman
three and then I have no problem at Tobey
Maguire.
Who's being Spiderman in this new guys?
Just twilight.
I think we've talked about
this twilight Parker.
That's what it felt like.
Like it's all sparkly
and it's got good hair.
It's just like overdramatic to
sexy and it's a love story also.
He's a superhero.
I liked them.
I have no problem with him.
Calm though.
But so how'd he,
how'd he get bit,
why'd you say Congo condos?
That doesn't make sense.
What does that,
what did that mean?
That condos,
a long time ago we talked about condos
and I was like let's buy them condos and
then I think it for Chrysler
or something like that.
It was so random access.
I was going to say maybe like you were
like if Joe was going to have sex with a
guy that would be his,
his,
oh scream.
I wouldn't be condos.
I bet there's a tumor the size of a
bowling ball and that kids had no,
I bet there's something in there now.
It's in my ass alien and that's why
we think there is one in the boat.
Me and Ari just started this new research
project or you might be able to help
us out.
When we were talking about it last night
that we both realized that we had her
but periods the same weekend and somebody
told me it might have something to do
with the moon at like the distance
of the moon is that you actually buy.
But what do you mean by out of your ass?
Like me and Ari both.
Have you guys both go
to Chipolte Portland?
No.
It had nothing to do with that.
Does this happen so often that you
think you could say it on a podcast?
We both had our but periods and
the photos hall would be like,
yeah,
I know what he's saying.
Like periods too.
A lot of people over
the age of 35 Oh Brian,
I've never,
I don't know anybody that's shitting blood
unless something really bad happened,
but I think you get a,
I will ponder this.
I think it has something to do.
Your research is about,
it's about the moon you think?
Yeah,
I think it has something to do with the
distance of the moon because both me and
art,
so we're going to start like,
you know,
putting it on our calendars every time
we ever bought periods and then you know,
see what else we were eating around
that time where I was going to put,
cause already made this great thing.
It's like just put everything that
you were doing at that time period.
Then after a while you'll see,
you have to remember
where it was going on.
Like,
you know,
the past day or two
before I used it as well.
You should just be fucking hemorrhoid.
Why are you even debating him on this?
This is crazy.
Do you start with have hemorrhoids?
Oh yes,
but they're internal so I don't think,
right.
They breed inside and
then you shit it out.
Like coated in a really
fine plastic layer of shit.
And it's really weird.
I think we've already figured this out.
But if it happens at the same
time as your blood brothers,
what you should do is both
caught you're assholes pushing,
rub them together and then tie him up
like an Indian would with some buckskin
and you need to stop grinding over and
making your butt's make out and rubbing
them together.
No,
that's how you become blood brothers.
You gotta tie your ass
cheeks together and then,
uh,
then you have to go through that speech
when the outlaw Josey Wales just seeing
if there's something that's there,
there's iron in your words of truth.
It's caught your APP.
Not Saying don't do the science.
I'm just saying you may.
What if there was a connection?
There was no science to,
I don't know why you talking
to this no science yet.
It's sort of saying,
why don't you have control over is Mike,
have you never have you not
asked point,
not trying quiet.
I'm that much trying to encourage
him to think that people are actually
listening.
There's probably better
ways to go about this navy.
So it turns out,
I have to say one thing,
it turns out that that story about the
Harvard doctor that wanted to implant a
neanderthal baby,
a woman's body,
it turns out it's bullshit.
Yeah.
Well he,
he,
he's,
yeah,
pretty much it's not,
it's not bullshit that he
wouldn't like to do it.
It's that there,
there isn't really a plan.
He just said,
you know,
that maybe we could,
yeah.
Maybe we have enough neanderthal DNA
or whatever that we could do that.
Yeah.
What happened was Blue Daily
Mail apparently picked up on,
uh,
this guy's conversation or have
ever listened to Daily Mail.
Yeah.
The Daily Mail's a bunch of cunts.
These fucks they,
um,
here,
I'll,
I'll pull up.
Ah,
okay.
Not True.
I'll see your file.
I can Google so I can get the whole story.
They were just talking about reviving
some extinct species that like we kind of
killed out a few decades ago.
Had just did that with a frog.
They just created the embryo of a frog.
We had Jacob Board from Popular
Science magazine yesterday.
Apparently what happened
was that there was a,
it was lost in translation
that it was originally,
it was for a,
uh,
a German language magazine called Der
Spiegel and was poorly translated about
the possibility of one
day cloning a neanderthal.
And they just ran it
through Google translation.
He,
you know,
and he,
when they asked him,
the guy said,
well,
I'm certainly not advocating,
but I'm saying that it's technically
possible Sunday if it is technically
possible someday we need to start talking
about it today and that we would need
a really adventurous woman.
So then they put out this thing saying,
asking for an adventurous woman
who wants to give birth to him,
murdering monkey man,
giant eyes.
They're murdering.
They might've been very peaceful.
I think everybody is a murderer back then.
Well,
there's that too.
Wouldn't need,
apparently they were,
they were very,
like,
they might have been ahead of,
uh,
the other group of,
of humans at that point.
Like they might've been a little more
advanced in terms of tool making.
And that's why as such a small group,
we let them like
interbreed with our heart,
not with ours,
they're both ours,
but like they integrate it.
The other group that was larger still
accepted them because they were so useful.
And that's how we got them.
The neanderthal
blood in us.
Yeah.
There's interbreeding
that's a possibility.
And the other possibility is just that
we share and even more similar common
ancestor and that there was a branch,
you know,
this way and that way and this way.
I mean,
like Africans don't have
the same neanderthal DNA.
Right,
right.
Your opinions and everybody else does.
Yeah.
There's thoughts that humans grew
in a variety of different forms,
including ones that we haven't
even totally discovered it.
You know,
that,
uh,
that Homo Floresiensis really throw a
monkey wrench into a lot of people's ideas
of the human past as well.
Cause they found a human,
a type of human,
this really tiny little human
that lived on one island,
um,
in the florists islands.
Is that when it's something like that?
Yeah,
something like that.
There's a weird thing that
happens to things on islands.
They get smaller except blizzards.
Lizards get bigger.
Is that right?
Yeah.
That's why the Komodo dragon so
fucking big and it's all stuck on one.
I wonder if that has to do with it cold,
warm blooded thing or wonder.
But it's a,
I,
it's called island dwarfism and there's,
um,
there's like a dwarf elephants and theirs.
That's adorable.
Yeah.
The little adorable elephants.
There's all these weird
things that happened.
There's like little small deer
and all these different animals,
monkeys and shit like that.
But this little human
was the weirdest one.
Little fucker innate.
There's a tiny human next time you got
to Houston or anybody in Houston and you
should go take out the,
the Museum of natural science.
They have this huge,
huge,
uh,
Paleontology holiday that just opened
up with like a massive train of stories
and like 40 some fossils,
but they also have this
huge history and lineage of,
of humans and they have this big
light cluster of them and I mean they,
they've got like 20 different kinds of
skulls or models of skulls in there and
all variety of shapes and sizes with
big ridges on their heads and shit like
that.
It's really interesting,
which they have this big ridge right in
the middle of their head to keep their
skull from breaking when
they chew on tough things.
Jesus Christ and a big ridge to keep their
skull from breaking when they chew on
the,
what the fuck.
A lot of the,
the hominids ha had this just like a
little extra ridge and it was just so when
you chew like the way you're,
you're bending your skull and shit,
it could,
it could just crack.
Wow.
How fascinating is that?
Pretty,
just think about the,
uh,
the idea of back then.
Did you have no stores?
No.
No metal,
no nothing,
no obligations except eating and shit.
Fucking like nobody
asks you to do anything.
You just,
yeah.
You only lived to be like 18.
If you're lucky and you're just running
around trying to catch shit to eat.
I,
although I don't know.
I don't know how long it
stretches back on the,
the age think they like it.
If you factor out baby death,
then the averages go up a whole lot.
Cause it's just fucking easy for a baby.
It's dykes.
They're so,
I
mean it,
it should be inside a womb and,
but the way,
the way that we,
we develop it comes out of the
womb and is still developing.
Well,
you know what man,
it's almost like nature knew that it
was a mistake to make people though,
like this fucking thing is
eventually going to blow us up.
Now it's just really hard to make people,
cause we're so fucking smart.
Yeah,
I know that.
But it's also the nature said,
let's make it easy to kill these fucks.
Yeah.
So you're seeing the onion article where
they compared the babies of various
species like in survival traits.
And there was one where they would put
the baby on top of a big pile of dirt and
let it rain in.
Every human baby would just sink in,
fucking drown in the mud.
All right.
I have no kids.
And you're both retarded.
Yeah.
So it goes
the,
yeah,
I think that it's easier for people to
die because if people could live like
easily,
if someone could create
what humans can create,
can be as smart as humans can,
can be able to alter their environment
as much as humans can and then also be
like,
is it vulnerables or rhino
thinking about how fun,
but it wouldn't be,
it's not so much,
uh,
you know,
nature meaning it's like,
it's a really precarious
balance to make it like,
you know,
like something like a third of our energy
consumption through day to day life.
It goes to our brain like,
and goes to keeping that your bets,
Huh?
Well he's got all that
carbon monoxide in there.
Keeping things running,
keeping it lubed up.
Yeah.
Sometimes you sneezing,
smokes comes out,
he hasn't even smoked.
That does happen.
No.
Like if you smoke a cigarette and then
like three minutes later you just pick
bourbon and a bunch of smoke comes like,
like,
Whoa,
what the fuck was that dude?
It's called cancer.
So I just learned something crazy that
there's a chemical and Gatorade that's
banned in like most countries,
uh,
from consuming including like Brazil,
Japan,
Canada,
India,
because it's bad for you,
like fucks with your thyroid.
It could get like transfer through
breast milk and I could fuck with your
neurological impairment
or impairment and uh,
it does all this bad shit to you
and it's in fucking Gatorade and uh,
you have to drink a lot of it to call.
Um,
it's called,
uh,
let's see.
Um,
brominated vegetable oil,
like bro Broner aid,
like bromine.
But uh,
it's,
yeah,
it's supposedly though,
I guess,
uh,
um,
Gatorade about to remove the ingredient,
but you know how long I had been around.
I know in this,
isn't Gatorade supposed
to be like drinking large
quantities because you're in
sports and you're like
getting dumped on your head.
And then if it comes true,
yeah.
But if it transfers to breast milk,
like what's it do to the little babies?
Your mom drinks,
like she's doing yoga and she drinks like
Gatorade and then transfers it through
a breasts.
What would it do to the baby?
Probably nothing good.
Yeah.
Or maybe filter it out.
We'll
when body's pretty resilient.
I don't know ruminated what vegetable oil.
It's just something they used the process
and I also just found out that equal,
uh,
just started re released,
stick to Stevia version of a Stevia.
They changed their formula
already have a second brand now.
So equal now has stevia.
Stevia is way better,
man.
Yeah,
it's a pretty good and
he uses an equal anyway.
Equal,
equal is smart.
They would just replace all
their equals with Stevia.
Well equal as a totally different
substance and they own a patent on it.
The problem with Stevia is it's just
a naturally occurring plant extract.
Yeah.
But isn't there a problem
with every one of them?
Like equal might lead to this
sweet and low might lead to this.
A lot of things might lead to like
Tim Ferriss or he says there's
no biological free ride.
If you,
uh,
if something tastes sweet,
it doesn't do anything bad to you.
You should fucking be scared.
Yeah,
you should be a little Frankie.
It's planning,
it's camping,
camping inside you planning.
It's attack
laying in a dormant state.
There's,
I mean,
we,
we get so over fed on the information
because there's like so many things you
could put into your body now.
Yeah.
But we don't,
we don't know what it is for like
everybody let alone or anybody like,
we don't know what Stevia,
Stevia is good or bad for everybody.
We don't know if this food
is good or bad for everybody.
Like we're all so individual and we don't
know the quantities and we don't have
the time to test all this new
shit that's out on the market.
So we're like over saturated
with information that is
kind of useless almost.
And like how many people have actually
died from a lot of the shit that we're
scared of?
Like who's died from diet coke?
Hmm.
No,
everybody's telling me that aspartame
is terrible as per tank as you can.
So I'm like,
why does everyone have cancer?
Because motherfuckers just
drink diet coke everywhere.
Everywhere you look.
People drink.
And someone said to me,
the,
the Tammy Baker and I said,
what?
He said,
Tammy Faye Baker,
she got cancer.
She drank like a case of diet coke a day.
Yeah.
That's the other problem.
Like you don't know if that did that,
especially with medical things.
He like,
you can't make that
connection unless it's like,
like the guy who figured out that uh,
uh,
stomach,
there were certain kinds of stomach
bacteria or viruses that caused ulcers and
everybody said it was bullshit.
And so he just took a very large dose
of the bacteria and he thought he would
wait a few weeks and,
and check out,
get like a colonoscopy,
gastro,
whatever.
And uh,
the next day he started
having stomach pains and,
and got checked out and he had a bunch
of holsters and his stomach and then,
and then he went to Nobel prize.
Wow.
For having the balls to step up.
But that that was a very obvious,
directly correlated this did that.
And 99% of shit is nothing like that.
Yeah.
And Tammy Faye Baker
was fucking Jim Baker,
you know,
and she was crazy.
She was a religious evangelists.
Who knows what gave that
lady cancer brain cancer.
Maybe that's why she was so crazy.
I don't know what kind of
cancer should cancel it.
Right.
So I have to correct
something I said earlier,
a gentleman from Holland said
that there is a drinking age,
16 for wine and beer and 18 for hard
liquor and it's apparently boss route.
And it was giving us dense this
information when he said there was no,
uh,
drinking some like rural area.
Apparently he's just
very loosely enforced.
They're not that,
uh,
they don't really give a fuck that much,
but that's pretty bad ass.
You can go to a bar,
have a beer when you're 18 or 2016 rather.
That's,
I said,
that's just hiding out
in your buddy's basement.
You know what I think you shouldn't
be able to do when you're 18?
I think you shouldn't
be able to make a porno.
I think that the team,
but yes,
it's the visually,
the most to me later.
Yeah.
But that's when people should
be getting watched younger.
No,
what I'm saying,
if you're a girl and um,
you know,
someone's going to exploit you and make
a film with you getting Gangbang by 50
dudes and they're all
nuts and your eyeballs,
I think you'd have to wait to be 21 point.
Make the decision 2142 we coded in common
at least three years of dudes lying
too,
so they can fuck you.
Yeah.
At least three more years where you go,
hmm,
there might be some fuckery afoot here.
I might be getting hosed
literally and figuratively.
You know,
just so you know,
it just,
what I saw that miss teen
Delaware or whatever it was,
was the young girl that
did a porn when she was 18,
like she's 18.
You imagine if we all were held to the,
we all just should be
judging those people.
Like we shouldn't judge people if they
want to fuck on or off camera anyway.
And if socially we were fine with it,
then we,
you know,
we wouldn't,
it wouldn't have been so shitty for her
to be found out that she was in a porn
like nobody,
nobody should give a shit
really,
except someone hired her,
recruited her,
do that.
Exploited her.
Yeah.
The summing.
Look,
if someone owns some multimillion dollar
porn company and there were recruiting
18 year old girls and they're
profiting off of them,
that's exploitation off of someone who's
fairly ignorant because they haven't
had a long life.
There's something about
that that I find offensive.
Maybe,
maybe they should be towards
education and not the choice itself.
That's 18 year olds are driving around
and better cars and all of us though,
you know,
they're driving a better car than me.
He stopped.
Well,
I mean most people,
you know,
I mean like a lot of fucking money.
They don't make a lot of mine.
That's not true.
They make $1,000 a scene if they're lucky.
Right.
It's not a lot of money.
It's not like practice for further career.
There might be,
don't get you're right about that,
but you're also riding
with like 18 years old,
I was getting paid $7 an hour.
These girls are getting paid $3,000.
You know,
it stopped for three hours.
So it doesn't mean anything.
That's,
so they're making enough
money to live temporarily.
They're not getting rich off of this shit.
You're acting like they're
driving rolls Royces.
Yeah.
Girls are not making that much money.
Like their fill all
players making millions.
How often do they work?
You know,
if you
worked every day of your life,
it's $365,000 a year to just
get gang bang constantly.
But nobody's really going
to pay you that anyway.
No.
And that would be exhausting.
Yeah,
you would do.
You would be dead.
You'd be dead by super aids
by the time you hit 17.
I just think it's,
um,
it's not that anybody
shouldn't be having sex.
It's not that.
Yeah,
that's fair.
That taking advantage of
other people should be,
I guess proper agencies like with few
psychiatrists on hand talk with them and
try to do the psych work.
People want to hit her porn and decide
whether or not there they're available or
uh,
or viable shit.
How do you decide to cut out the dumb
ones without cutting out the crazy ones?
Cause the crazy ones,
clearly you got to keep
fuck how do you,
because some of the
crazy ones are awesome.
Why can't you just have the crazy ones?
But how do you,
when do you know how to cut someone loose?
Go.
Yeah,
she's just free spirited and you know,
what she needed to do was just sorta,
she's thinking about hitchhiking across
the country where their cousin or,
you know,
she wants to fuck 500 guys in a day.
Let's just let her,
yeah,
the veteran filming,
you know,
it's not even necessarily crazy.
Just a very peculiar and very significant.
Did you ever see that documentary came
out a few years back about Annabella
Chong?
I didn't even know that.
She's the one that was the first.
Um,
and she was the first gal to do
one of those crazy gang bang thing.
I'm my Jags,
she knows her Houston at the age of 21.
She had sex with a 251 sex acts
with 69 men over a 10 hour period.
Wow.
And it was called the
world's biggest gang bang.
Since then,
gals have a,
they've taken it to the next level
and they,
they,
um,
now I think like a Houston
did like 500 sex acts.
They pretend it's 500 guys.
But just like these poor guys have
to go back for a second sister.
I did not know that.
And these gals,
by the way,
if you've never seen one of those
Nutty Gang Gang Bang thingamajigs it is
fucking in sanity.
I mean completely insanity.
It's like medical.
It's like who's turn is it?
Your turn hop on up Phil.
And it's completely crazy.
There's all these people
waiting like my friend,
um,
his,
Tyler Knight,
is this a porn name?
We've had him on the podcast for good guy.
He wrote a m a blog entry.
Fine.
Yeah,
the great,
great stuff.
He wrote a blog entry about his
time in the line on a gang bang.
And he couldn't do it.
He couldn't get it up.
But it said it was just the most
wretched experience that you could ever
possibly imagine.
And he wrote about like being poor and
needing this money and standing in spoons
and shuffling his way to
the front of the line.
And I remember him writing
something about how you need to,
to bring flip flops
to the porn set.
Yes.
That terrified me right there.
Especially certain gang bangs walking
through the carpet and the carpet's light.
It's not wet until you
step on it cause he like,
seeps out and then seeps back in.
Awful.
This Gal,
Bella Chong who did this,
uh,
she was,
she's very intelligent.
It was really weird.
I,
and I'm pretty sure that she was attending
UCLA when she did this or she went to
UCLA or something like that.
See now she should totally be USC
graduate work gender studies at USC.
Wow.
Was that her thesis?
That's funny.
John presented her work in pornography
as an attempt to challenge with settled
notions of assumptions of what you,
yours is about female sexuality.
For example,
her conception of a gang bang was
based on the example of Mess Alina.
Uh,
wife of the emperor of
Claudius historically mess
Alina had suffered a poor
reputation.
The fact that some attributed
at least partly to gender bias,
according to Chung,
she sought to question the
devil standard at design.
Denies Women.
The ability to exhibit the same sexuality
as men by modeling what a female stud
would be.
So she's saying she's a female stud by
letting the 69 homeless guys shoot loads
and your hair,
that's not even a guy that
shows up and bank 69 women.
You're going to go,
hey dude,
what are you doing?
That dude,
I don't know if that,
okay,
well famously there was that guy with
the Houston game pain that like went down
on it,
right?
Brought her flowers number.
Like two 71 or something?
No.
Oh my crimee they brought her flowers.
Which do you think is
weird or the flowers?
It's just she could buy
that at a store that,
that could even leave that.
Well obviously you know those
flowers meant something to him,
but he went down on her.
What if he locked onto a pussy,
like a pit bull and it couldn't pull
him off and all the other guys and she's
screaming,
he's biting her pussy.
I'm sure it was too
slick for him to really,
yeah,
he's probably a fucking fish.
Try catching a fish eye.
Has anybody ever jumped in the river
and caught a fish with their teeth?
Western happened.
It must have happened at least once.
I had this a Hawaiian teacher
and elementary school that uh,
he,
he told us these stories
about like the 15 year olds,
I don't know if this was bullshit.
I don't think so though.
But the teens would like swim out into
really shallow waters with like three
foot sharks and they would swim next
to them and then and bite their eye and
when you punched her their eye,
they just like,
they just stopped moving completely
and then you can grab them by the,
by the tail and just drag them on
cause they won't move or anything.
I Dunno.
Wow.
Bold people before us and
figure these things out.
Well,
once you started swimming
with sharks and you're like,
ah,
sharks are also delicious.
They are tasty and there's a
lot of meat to those fuckers.
It makes sense if you could figure
out how to get them on the boat.
That's the hard part.
Yeah.
Sharks tastes good.
It tastes like swordfish.
I didn't have a lot of
things age sharks before.
There were boats.
Yeah.
Right.
Can you imagine how different the world
was until people figured out how to make
metal things and me for
the longest time it's like,
oh,
what'd you do?
You made a knife with a rock.
Congratulations Pussy.
You have nobody.
Nobody was really worried and then as
soon as they started figuring out how to
melt down metal,
then it was like,
Ooh,
what can we do with that?
Fucking cities within cities,
a rubbed guns start going off.
Planes are flying,
dropping bombs,
nuclear fucking re rate the rest
of the world that he's crazy.
Monkeys.
Look at the fuck they did.
We got smile.
Just figured out how to make metal.
That's all metal and then electricity.
It's like,
okay,
we need to put these two together
and see what the fuck is up.
Very clever on that front too.
The nuttiest monkeys out of all time.
And although we used to think some
pretty stupid shit about like all,
I mean we,
we used to think cold was a thing and
like w cold was a thing with and the way
that heats kind of a thing or a descriptor
of a thing were hotter things move
more.
We used to think,
oh,
it's like a thing.
And here did have the absence of heat.
Yeah.
And they,
they would like put buckets of like a uh,
ice or something up high and then they
would watch the steam roll down and then
go see like cold is heavy.
Cold is heavier than heat.
So that's why it falls.
Oh,
that's interesting.
They didn't realize that.
It was just the,
the act of just the characteristic
steric statistical function of the heat.
You know what I found out today that
sulfur has to boiling points is a very
strange thing that sulfur,
when you heat it,
it becomes like this liquid.
And then if you heat it again,
the liquid becomes a solid,
like the solid rock solid.
And then if you heat it again,
it becomes a liquid again.
It re re forms into different things.
I think that's so cool about like Adams.
There's just like three things basically.
And um,
it's just electrons,
protons and neutrons.
And you just change the number of those
and the behavior radically changes.
You have chlorine,
which has got like 11,
11 protons in it and
it's like a noxious gas.
It's like kind of green.
It can kill.
Yeah.
Shit like that.
And then you have sodium,
which is like 17 protons
and it's solid and a,
it reacts with water to ignite.
It actually ignites with water.
And then you put them together
and you get table salt.
No fucking sense.
Well how about the fact that they can
take things that are absolutely illegal
and then just change a little bit
of them and then sell them as bath,
salt research chemicals,
sir?
Research Chemicals.
Now remember,
we used to be able to get DMT online,
not,
not regular DMT,
but five methoxy DMT used to be able to
go to the American Chemical Company and
by research chemicals,
that's what they were calling.
There's still places like they
cause like their laws are about,
uh,
you know,
they make a law about the chemical and
then somebody makes an analog when they
change one of the pieces out and then it,
it is technically illegal,
but not until somebody says specifically
that that chemical's illegal.
So,
so they have that amount of time to
sell it and market it or whatever.
And then they catch up
to it and then they,
oh okay,
we'll switch out this one and
they keep going down the line.
Yeah.
Well that's what they do with those
dick hardening pills to Brian buys these
fucking things that like Brian was
telling me some lovely stories.
The prize of the gas stations,
the apparently those are the ones who
want the gas stations that are owned by
real dude's 76 is the best one to go to.
The gas station Shell Shell and seven 11.
Don't get the good ones.
You've got to get the real sketchy joints,
liquor stores,
those ones that'll bump liquor
stores real sketchy jointly.
And what it is really is just Viagara.
They just buy bulk Viagra or Cialis
and it's cheaper for them to sell that.
Like they'll sell you a tense night.
Incredibly illegal or anything.
It's totally illegal.
But they don't even get in trouble
for it because nobody's doing tests.
Yeah,
they get two warnings.
Warnings.
That's awesome.
And then that just name the company.
But these things,
you know,
as long as people know they work,
like he found out they
work in this motherfucker,
he's like he's taking stock in the
company if you are temporary stock.
But if you like,
if they were doing that and selling
it as Viagara or selling it at Cialis,
it's way cheaper.
So it's actually more
profitable for them to sell.
They're nutty Dick Pills
and like a little package.
So an impulse buy and they're always
like right in front of you when you go to
pay.
They don't hide those bitches.
They're right in front next to like the
energy pills and you already spending
money,
you're going to get a pack of gum lighter.
Let me get my 30 pills.
They cards.
Yeah.
Um,
apparently GNC and uh,
um,
the company that make Jack Three d is
getting sued again cause another dude
died.
So I think they're going to pull that
if they haven't pulled that shit off all
stores.
I think they're going what
was in there like good.
All the good stuff.
Good.
Anything good gets taken away.
So we lost a few.
Okay.
Listen folks,
think about how many we helped
get rolling the dice every day.
Rolling dice.
Exactly.
I mean,
people have died from Viagra to,
but people like,
you know what?
It's worth it.
But the old white dudes are in charge and
they loved their Viagara and old white
dudes are the ones that die anyway and
they figure fuck those other old white
dude.
So I'm tired of this bullshit.
Yeah.
Especially old white dudes just barely
hanging on and looking at this crazy
stack of cash thinking,
okay,
what I've got maybe six years left.
Who can I put a fucking two right now.
I've got a bunch of money and
I still don't feel like a man.
Just some assistance.
Well it would be nice if they actually
had clarity and if they realize
listening,
which just go balls out and then
run this bitch right into the,
you know,
just fucking hit the throttle
until we hit the beach.
Something more fun.
I mean when once you,
like if you stopped caring about sex and
stop getting hard on like how much shit
would you get done?
Nothing.
Cause you would have no drive.
This is what I say one thing for sure.
When you stop fucking,
you should stop driving at that age.
They should,
uh,
which they should do is instead of a
test to see if you know how to drive
fucking guy's 80 years old,
they should know how to drive and
get them in a room with like Alexis,
Texas.
Okay.
And you know your higher yeah.
Hired to just gently rub his balls and
say sweet things to him and suck on his
ears.
And if his dick gets hard and,
and he can have sex with her,
give him his license.
If not,
get the fuck out of here.
I'm super glad to don't run shit and if
he can up super glad I'm not serious.
But if he could,
uh,
if as long as even if he could
take Viagra and stay alive,
he can drive.
But if you stop fucking get off the road,
fuck off the road,
what are you doing?
And you getting to just
think about what the end,
because you're driving around.
How do I know you're not just going to
hit the fucking gas and drive right into
a bank?
I don't know.
How do I know life is over?
How do I know your motivation?
I think that's,
you know,
I mean it's one of the most standard
things.
What do you think about
like angry people standard?
You think about them being unfuckable,
you know,
the no one,
no one wants them.
They're lonely.
They're desperate.
Angry people on the Internet.
I mean,
how much of a cliche is that?
The meanest,
nastiest,
angry people who have zero chance of
getting any pussy ass beating their Dixon
to the ground on porn,
on the Internet,
and then yelling at people
and no one loves them.
Rylands
yeah.
Then what happens?
Huh?
Then what happens
is poor fox,
they get all angry and they get crazy.
Get nutty.
If we could just find people to fuck them,
look at settle the whole thing down.
But the problem is they
might be your kids.
J D absolutely not.
Most kids are anybody's kids.
It could be anybody's kids.
You say absolutely not yours,
but one day,
maybe so and then one day.
What if you know,
we need people to volunteer for the armed
service in Iraq or the department of
motor vehicles to fuck all people.
What would you take?
Do you want your [inaudible] Glenn?
I would want my kid going to the DMV.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
sex above violence.
Sex with old is probably violence.
Hell,
don't blow people up.
He's just blow them
and keep our roads safe.
Keep everybody happier.
A lot of people going be happy.
Well that's the problem with,
with uh,
prostitution to prostitution's legal.
I mean,
somebody is fucking somebody's kid,
but I mean somebody who's probably doing
that anyway and I kids enjoying it.
But what if that kid's
doing it for a living?
It's good.
Are they good at it?
To me,
there isn't a natural though that we
have this aversion to that prostitution.
Yeah.
I'd been prostituted if I was a girl.
No,
I don't think there's any,
no,
get me wrong.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with prostitution,
but I think there is,
there's a natural aversion to
everything I think are in his gun.
Sound fucked up.
But I think our system exactly as it
is right now is absolutely natural.
Our jealousy,
I nonsense.
Our hypocrisy are every,
every weird aspect about our culture
from feminism to progressive's to
Republican ards to,
you know,
to the top,
to the bottom,
from conservative to liberal.
I think it's all natural.
I think we are in charge of the actual
is I'm a wolf colony in the islands
valence natural,
like aren't we a little smarter than that?
Yeah,
I would think so.
Yes,
but I'm not sure because I'm thinking
sometimes I think yes we are because we're
self aware,
but look at how everything continues
to move basically in the same sort of
interaction.
It's the mass.
It's definitely moving as one.
I'm like,
yes,
not really paying attention clearly as
one despite the massive access to it that
we have now and I wonder it's,
but I want you to think of that me be,
but I wonder if also even that is a
part of the process that the access to
information like slowly but surely a
truth evolves it into another thing and
that all of these are natural reactions
is just so complex and multifaceted and
fractal that from the outside looking
in or even from the inside looking out,
it's very hard to
understand and recognize.
That's why all natural,
I'm pretty like,
I'm not super interested
in like getting to,
like,
I don't want to lead any movements or
anything because shit's just like the
human race is going to
do what it's going to do.
And I mean,
I could tweak it,
but I'm kind of content to just watch
and see because it's going to develop or
we're going to crash into the dirt.
But it,
the human race is moving.
It's like,
like trying to stop a flood.
Yeah.
Who was it that said that was an Einstein?
Someone said that the
human races involved in,
uh,
human beings are involved in a race
between education and catastrophe.
I don't think I've heard that.
Someone said it wasn't Sam.
Truthfully,
there's someone like him,
so great man.
Um,
I don't remember who the,
but I've always felt that when
I first read that I was like,
yes,
that's what I've always felt like,
man,
I hope we get it together first.
You know,
like I always felt like
when I was growing up,
when I was a kid in high school,
um,
it was the red scare and everyone was
really legitimately worried that we're
going to have a nuclear war with Russia.
Like you'd go to school,
you go to history lessons and they would
show you Hiroshima and Nagasaki and you
know,
the effects of nuclear
bombs and you're like,
whoa.
And everybody was terrified when
I was in school that we were,
and that's where red dawn came
from and all that crazy shit.
Everyone was scared.
Um,
but I think sometimes when
you look at human behavior,
when you look at just even the
most fucked up aspects of it,
I really do wonder if all that
shit is not a natural part of our,
like our motivation to,
to move forward.
Like why would
careful how we got here,
why we wouldn't be here
if we weren't successful.
And we have to assume that just about
everything that people do is part of that
success.
Otherwise it would have
been weaned out somewhere.
So it,
so it was useful like for survival.
And then the night,
now we've got some new,
there's also that aspect of humans
where we don't really get anything done
unless we're desperate,
you know?
I mean,
when do you reactionary,
when you're fat and rich and
you've got all the money you need,
how motivated are you to get up and run?
I'm all good.
If you live in a warm climate and you've
got to stick to pull termites off of
out of a hill,
like why,
why do anything?
Yes,
you can eat those termites.
Well,
have you ever,
you know,
you know those things that people do,
like when they lose a job,
where they get their shit together,
like they get fired from a job and all
sudden they'll tell you a year later it
was the best thing that ever happened
to me and made me get my shit together,
made me getting gear.
I started pursuing the
career I really wanted.
Now I'm super happy.
But for awhile there,
man,
I was fucking scared.
And that is what motivated people.
That's,
that's what motivated,
uh,
I've,
I've talked to so many people
that have had that issue.
Breakups.
Do it too.
You get dumped and then you realize I
am kind of a fucking loser and you need
your shit together.
It's like it's super
common with people.
It's not until you get
it pointed out to you,
you know,
like not until he gets scared.
Yeah.
Desperate.
Whether you're scared of the Russians,
are you scared of the North Koreans?
Are you scared of Al Qaeda?
It's almost like these sort of scenarios
and situations are almost like put in
place in order for us to continue,
continue this movement as a whole.
This bizarre.
Yeah.
If not that something else,
like something needs to come along or,
I mean,
you know,
we,
if we keep just doing the same
thing over and over and over,
as we,
as everything else keeps growing,
like that one behavior isn't going to
fit the same pattern when it's larger.
So we have to,
it's like switching gears.
You've got to constantly find something
new to deal with the new environment,
steel with new,
the new everything.
So you a,
I know that you listen to this podcast
on occasion and I know also in the,
you're a very bright young man and also
a tad skeptical or share a little bit.
Is there anything that
really stood out recently?
Anything where you were listened
to the podcasts were like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well I,
I mean the easy ones career I guess,
but we could talk a little bit.
What are you trying to say sir?
Uh,
I mean that guy was obviously a shyster.
How dare you,
how dare bulls.
Are you
trying to educate the world
about the alien invasion?
Possible?
Imminent alien invasion doesn't seem as
worried and this is perhaps someone else
because he's huge.
But yeah,
he's pretty good.
It's got a giant arms and shit.
He's ready to fight anybody.
He just sounds like all of the
other scammers doesn't eat.
I got a little bit,
uh,
he's got DNA evidence.
Apparently he hasn't put
out soon to be released.
I don't think that she
is soon to be released.
But if the mood,
like why would you wait?
Skeptical.
He's get a DNA.
DNA.
You remember recently the,
the,
the big foot DNA thing?
Yes.
Melba catch him.
Yeah.
And you know what they
did was they made up,
have their own journal and made up
their own journal and then you go to the
journal and you go to the list of
articles and it's just that one fucking
article.
And even there they didn't
put like they don't,
why wouldn't you put the information out?
Aren't,
aren't they?
Why aren't these people
are always concerned about
information about information
being free and shit.
The,
the big foot thing is very funny.
I Wa I have gotten to the point where,
um,
I watch finding bigfoot,
I fucking Dvr,
Dvr it.
And I just fast forward to the parts
where they in the woods with a night
vision.
Cause these mother fuckers
never see shit ever.
But they'd been on for two seasons now.
So it's two seasons of every week.
They're in the woods,
every week's cheapest shit.
Like why would they cancel?
It was just two assholes in the
woods with some night vision.
How that,
you'd know that.
The crazy thing about that show is that
even more so than like storage wars,
you know,
they're really not finding anything.
And if they did find it,
you would hear about it on TV.
Just like the ghost hunters.
Yes.
Well the ghost hunters,
you know,
the ghost hunters are really interesting.
I watched a,
I don't remember which show it was,
but that the guys act,
I think his name is Zack Baggins.
He's the head guy.
It seemed,
it was a fun show.
They were drinking and
doing shots and shit.
I was like,
wow,
this isn't your regular
a ghost hunter show.
But then they went to this,
uh,
this place that was supposed to be
haunted and they recorded a sound like you
could hear like a woman's voice.
And I was like,
wow,
that's fucked.
I wonder what the fuck that really was.
Whether it's fuckery,
whether it's,
you know,
someone's playing games,
whether,
whether the house has a memory,
but I still have never seen a fucking,
something like Gumroad.
Deltoros Mama,
you know,
running the camera like the best,
the best evidence they can ever give
you is we don't know what it is.
Like it's either like you,
fos it's,
you could point out,
oh maybe it was this,
maybe it was that.
But you can never,
it's never any better than,
I don't know.
Yeah.
But the UFO places that they,
when the or the ghost places
when they go looking for them,
they like look for heat
signatures and shit like that.
And they,
they,
they wear these clothes that actually
have like thermometers on the close to
detect cool breezes and shit.
Oh,
cool.
Breeze indicates of ghostly presence.
I don't know if he knew that.
I didn't know that.
You know,
you can detect magic
with machinery is scary.
Cool breeze could be um,
a voice from beyond.
So every evening I'm
enjoying the ghostly manners.
Sopping up from a lake side or something.
A joke.
You posted a photo of you eating
a raw horse meat the other day.
Why the fuck would you do that?
Like,
why would you like that?
Is this a disgusting?
But that's pretty scary to do
because of the parasites and shit.
No,
actually I'm a horse doesn't
really have parasites.
Well you have to worry about parasites
in mostly carnivorous animals.
Like you have to worry
about parasites and pigs.
That's what pigs,
it's very important to cook them all the
way through because you can get strict,
uh,
or trigger gnosis.
And that's an horse chicken Dosa
that's found in horse a lot actually.
And Horsley cross contamination.
It's probably a shitty
a place that doesn't,
um,
winning,
we'll call it,
uh,
take care of the meat.
Right.
But,
uh,
with cows,
um,
people do it all the time.
I think the real thing
to worry about the cows,
he lie.
I don't think you have to
worry about tricking houses.
Yeah,
it should.
We do with bears you deal with,
you deal with horse.
It's actually pretty common.
Uh,
it also,
it's a bait.
There's no way for them to test
what drugs the horse had had,
had,
had been given.
I had heard my horse had all the drugs,
how it helps.
Like it could be given some,
some,
some bad shit.
And it maybe,
you know what,
we,
uh,
we ended at Joe Beef,
this place of Montreal and I had
horse meat the last time I was there.
I had a like,
cooked and this time they served at Ra.
We just ate everything they brought over.
We didn't question cause they're awesome.
These guys are that we had,
um,
we had veal that wasn't,
uh,
like when you think of veal,
you think of a baby cow that they take
and they tie it up and they feed it milk.
This was just a baby cow.
That's kind of,
I was like,
man,
that's kind of fuck up.
They killed his cow young.
But then it's like,
why is it better lives to be 10?
And then they kill it.
Like I don't get,
it doesn't really,
they're killing them.
It's not like,
you know,
it's not,
well,
it's not like it missed out
on like football games and TV.
I don't think they traipse
through daisies or anything.
I don't know how much their life,
they're really,
I mean,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have done it myself,
but they had already killed it,
so I hate it.
Um,
and then they had,
um,
a bunch of other weird shit
that they brought over.
But the restaurant,
if you're ever in Montreal,
you got to go there.
It's called Joe Beef.
The place is incredible.
It looks really good.
It's amazing.
The horse thing gets to me.
I want to just wanna eat
horse and to eating it raw.
Just I'd like when I was a little weird.
It's fucking delicious,
man.
I'm telling you.
It's delicious.
It's really tasted ice cream,
both cooked and raw,
um,
that uh,
that Joe beef place.
Oh,
the other thing they have is this
thing called the fog was double down.
You know how like Kentucky Fried Chicken
has that double down where it's too
chicken patties and cheese
and ridiculously decadent
chicken.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The bread becomes chicken.
Well,
they did that with fall.
Guam with Fagua is,
um,
it's,
this should be a better way to say that.
It doesn't sound so fucking pretentious.
I'm having Fagua Darling in a Chablis.
It's a Ross.
It's duck liver.
They take a duck's liver and it actually
became illegal in California recently.
My favorite place to get it
at this restaurant doesn't
serve it anymore because
people became p,
uh,
like Peta and animal rights people.
Um,
they,
they made this campaign,
it tried to stop people from doing it
because they force feed these ducks,
they force feed them and their
livers blow up their livers.
Livers get huge.
And when is it a duck or geese?
Duck.
Okay.
Right.
I think my biggies,
let's,
let's bow tie V,
whatever it is.
It could be both.
It's both actually.
You've both duck or goose.
Um,
they,
they force feed them.
They put it like a feeding tube down
their throat and they pump them up with
food and then it makes
their liver grow huge.
And then you take that
liver and you cook it.
What's really fucked up is
you can't do that anymore,
but you can still eat them
so you can still kill him.
But now you got to throw
away their liver out.
Yeah.
You can't even have like
organically harvested,
non forced fed.
They can't even do liver.
No,
you just can't eat duck liver.
Whether or not it's being force fed.
I don't think you're allowed to
sell it at a restaurant anymore.
I mean I think if it's your own duck.
What's that?
I just thought it's something,
I think if it's your own duck and maybe
like you're slaughtering your own duck,
you're allowed to eat it's liver,
but I'm pretty sure the band
is not just because of um,
first aid and force feeding.
And by the way,
if you see a farm,
these um,
the like these animals actually hover
around the force feeding tube because they
want to get fed.
Well,
it's easy.
Sure.
It's not only that,
it's like it looks horrific to us that
they take a tube and throw it down.
They don't have gag reflexes.
They don't look,
they don't have an awareness that like
all it's doing is making their liver fat
like,
and we're like,
it's so horrible.
What about the fact that we're going
to cut it fucking head off and cook it?
Is that,
what should we stop doing that?
I mean it's step one to stop doing that.
It's what it is.
It's like a slow road to someone telling
you there's something wrong with it.
Like sweet killed all their predators.
And then I guess it's our
responsibility to be killing them.
We asked to kill them,
but even if we don't kill their predators,
what predators are ducks?
How also ducks,
her rapist,
brutal rubbish.
But they don't have a lot of predators.
I mean the once we want to bring
crocodiles to every fucking pond,
the,
the number one Predator
for ducks as humans,
there's really not a lot of other things.
Killing ducks.
I think cars,
you know,
I mean,
what the fuck is it
getting killed by a duck?
That just made me really sad killing.
I think I've ever seen
a duck hit by a car.
Really.
It's like this and then its feathers
and shit and you're not even allowed to
pick that duck up and cook
it with strange people.
I've been talking to,
um,
you know,
I,
I went hunting and I shot that deer,
that deer head that's right there.
And I've had,
um,
some legit conversations
with people that are intelligent
people that actually are upset by that.
And even people that eat meat.
And I'm like,
why you,
you know that if you eat meat,
somebody had to do that.
So many different though
between knowing yeah.
Was right in front of you.
Like I'm most me is like unrecognizable
and it looks like Plato where something
like a steak burger.
Yeah.
Right.
But that disconnect between the person
and the act of actually doing the thing
and killing the thing anyway.
Fuck Wad double down.
If you're in Montreal,
it's the shit they take.
They,
they deep fry a piece of fog wall with
like Kentucky Fried Chicken type of
breading on the outside
with cheese in the center.
It's unbelievable.
It's so good.
Yeah.
There's a photo of our eating it on my,
my not my own on a tumbler,
my whatever the fuck it is.
Uh,
Instagram,
there's Instagram and
there's this group and,
and Houston that uh,
uh,
like once a month they get together and
everybody brings like meat and food and
they slice it up and,
and share like everybody shares
all the food they bring in.
And the guy that heads it,
uh,
he,
he picked up some rabbits from a pet store
and he's been breeding them for food.
Whoa.
It's pretty neat.
Pretty tasty.
I had some,
uh,
it might've been liver or something.
I don't know if it's worth a little bit,
a little bit,
but then you,
you come in,
you're hanging out with people,
you learn a little bit.
Some,
isn't it weird though this um,
this,
this distinction we have
one way or the other,
you know like rabbit,
Ooh you're crossing into gray area.
But if you kill the cat,
hey man,
don't kill cats.
Like,
like there aren't too many cats.
Can't kill a dog.
But I watched Ted Nugent shoot a coyote
and the head today he has traps set up
around his property.
I think that's actually part of a lot
of like the reason people and in urban
areas are like environmental activists.
Like most of the environmental activist
are there cause cause we killed all the
unpleasant animals that live in cities.
It's just like squirrels
and birds tweeting around
and everything's lovely and
adorable.
You never seen a wolf
ripping a cow apart backyard.
No asshole animals live in the city.
We got rid of him.
Yeah.
So that's your view of nature.
It's just really pleasant.
I posted this thing about wolves and
they got into this sort of debate about
wolves when people were talking about,
you know,
like uh,
plans on killing wolves and people here,
the tar,
how could you kill a wolf?
How could you,
and then I posted this list of people
killed by wolves throughout history and
it's a pretty fucking substantial,
is that right?
The reason why we have these like Little
Red Riding Hood and the big bad wolf
and all these wolf images in and
our past and stories and stuff,
it's because wolves were
killing people all the time.
I mean it was fairly common.
There was a time in France where in
Paris a wolves killed more than 40 people
huffing and puffing and Park in Paris.
Mac when it looked
like a gangs of New York neighborhood.
Yeah,
exactly.
What that showed.
You see this dog or this a dog whisperer
video that they posted recently of him
getting attacked by a dog?
No Way.
Yeah,
I won't play the audio so it won't,
so hopefully you won't get pulled,
you know.
Uh,
but it's called dog whisperer show
down with Holly and Holly Band.
It gets pretty crazy cause he was saying
like how this dog is barking and he'd
look like try it bites him right there
and then he kicks the dog dog fucked him
up.
And then if,
if after a while his hand starts
getting really swol and uh,
just starts bleeding,
blood just starts pouring out of his hand.
His hands fucked right now dog.
No,
that dog bit the shit out of him,
man.
I taught clamped on outlook.
What's up?
Yeah,
he's cornering it.
He's been standing there for me.
See if this works.
His genitals right?
Yeah.
She's still not submissive.
Damn.
Um,
yeah,
he's,
why would you even get
so close to look at that?
Oh,
he's a strange cat.
This guy,
you're seeing the things he does with
dogs and one of the things he does is he
kicks them on the side.
Yeah,
you just tapped him on the side,
which I actually took some on the
body that I don't like kick it hard,
but my dog and my parents' dog when we're
like playing tug of war and I just tap
her as she gets pissed,
but she doesn't want to let go.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
When there's a domination,
does she bite him again?
No.
Does he see now is when
she started smiling?
So now you can't look
at it took five minutes,
but just staring at the dog until he,
whatever turns around.
Yeah,
that's a pussy dog.
Try that shit.
What a rottweiler or a pit bull that grabs
a hold of your hand and won't let go.
I a Ui Ouchie Ouchie yeah,
that guy.
Uh,
he's,
you know,
it's a dog.
You can't always get a dog
to do what you want to do.
Their fucking head.
You gotta be a weird dude.
Maybe that's what that is.
So this a episode of the Ted
Nugent show that I watched today.
He's a,
he's got these traps set up all around
his property because he lives on hundreds
of acres and he hunts in his
yard like Montana or something,
right?
No,
he's got two places.
He's got a place in Michigan
but he doesn't live in anymore.
And now he lives in Texas and in
Texas he lives outside of Waco and um,
he's got this huge ranch,
like hundreds of acres with wild animals
running around all over the ranch.
And it's Kinda crazy.
Like it's a hunting show.
Okay.
But then it's not really
any hunting going on.
They sit out there waiting for the animals
to show up for the food and then they
fucking shoot him.
And he does.
It's the same show every week?
No,
it's fishing in a barrel.
It's fishing than you toilet bowl.
It's taking a carp and throw
it into the toilet bowl.
It's,
it's crazy.
I mean,
it's a great way to get meat,
but I mean,
I'm watching what he does everyday.
Literally walks to corn,
won't do that.
He gets into a tree stand.
Okay.
And he's got a dude with them when the
camera and then he fucking leaves the
food up and you know,
every week he's successful,
he gets skunked.
I mean this the show,
I was on the show,
a meat eater when we shot
this deer and it was,
you know,
we had a hike for three days.
We're in Montana.
It's,
it's difficult like you have to pull
to actually get a shot on an animal.
You have to go through a
lot of work to get there.
Ted Nugent,
it takes 10 minutes.
He sits at his tree stand.
Every show is the same fucking thing.
They come to the food,
he shoots them and he's like,
can you believe that?
He gets all crazy that we got and we got
and we got 'em we got 'em like he was
right there.
If they are coming to eat food,
like it's kind of,
it's the whole thing is kind of crazy.
But he's got,
I would hope he gets that
excited off camera too.
Like that's just him I
think maybe a little bit.
I mean he look,
bowhunting is fun,
you know,
I'm sure you get a little bit excited,
but a little bit is of him
being corny for the camera.
But before,
um,
that's the beginning of the episode.
Then later in the episode,
he's got his dogs with him.
He's talking about great dogs are,
and then he goes and shoots a coyote,
which looks just like his fucking dogs.
I mean,
they're there.
They're real similar,
but it's that thing where
we make a distinction.
You know,
we decide like you're my friend.
You can go fuck yourself.
You're going to eat rabbits that
you found from the pet store.
Ooh.
I don't know how many
to cow that I raised.
Well,
that's normal.
You know,
we have like animals that
are our buddies and animals,
like a coyote that looks
like a fucking Cali.
I mean,
how was it coyote that dissimilar
from a German shepard or a coyote?
Just slightly less friendly.
Yeah.
Yes.
They don't care for us either.
Maybe that's part of it.
Squirrels are into us.
Coyote is not so much.
I understand what Ted Nugent
is killing the coyote.
He's killing the coyote because he has a
huge piece of property filled with deer
and coyotes eat the Fonz.
That's like,
um,
the,
and he was saying that before
he bought this property,
the people that owned it before him,
you know,
like that's what you buy.
You're buying like these
deer management land,
uh,
things.
And the people that owned it before him,
they,
um,
they didn't trap so they
never killed the coyotes.
So they just,
they lost every fall and they ever had,
so every year the coyotes would come
in looking for fonts and snatch him up.
So whenever the,
the deers would,
uh,
give birth,
the entire population will be decimated.
So all they have is old deer.
So he had to go.
So,
so people don't understand,
like why would someone go around
and she's tired cause his knee,
they're like managing the deer.
And yet if they kill all the funds that
then what you kill all your deer off to
the,
you'd have nothing left,
but you only need to kill
it one or two deer a year.
And he's,
I think he's got hundreds of them.
But the point is like,
someone from an urban environment
would not understand that.
They would say,
well,
why do you have to kill the coyote?
Don't kill a coyote.
Okay,
you're going to sit back and
watch the coyote kill baby deer.
What do you,
what do you more happy about?
Yeah.
Then under c that they never have
to address nature killing nature.
Exactly.
Just never have to train and killing
nature because we're not nature.
We're not unnatural nature
killing nature with its face,
which I surely do if I could.
I certainly four and 14,
50.
Um,
if you look up wolves
of Paris in Wikipedia,
there's a pretty,
a detailed depiction of what
happened in the winter of 1450.
Uh,
there was breaches in the walls
of that's not good of Paris.
And,
uh,
there was one wolf is really fucked up.
This wolf was like
missing part of its tail.
And that was the,
uh,
the leader of the pack of these wolves.
And,
uh,
they went into the city of Paris and
they started fucking killing people.
And so they,
uh,
they,
the,
the Persians,
because 40 fucking people were killed.
They learned these wolves into the heart
of the city and they stoned and speared
them to death in front of
the Notre Dame cathedral.
It's for Roxanne.
Yeah.
Throw rocks and spears is,
that's all.
Yeah.
Well I don't think they,
they have guns in 14,
15.
I don't think so.
No,
no,
I think and,
and when did they invent the gun?
Uh,
not that long ago.
1450 was like when it was invented.
I mean,
that was like
bad days for technology
and checking on back.
1464,
1464 now.
Shit.
Yeah.
The first gun.
The first time at Thompson 1464 human
history to history cast from bronze.
Yeah.
Um,
that broke all the fucking time.
Yeah,
those probably sucked with,
makes sense though because like
a canon is basically a gun.
Just a big stupid gun.
I like a grant.
Morrison,
that comic writer,
he has a,
he has a quote about guns that
it's an explosion in one direction.
Wow.
Even crazy.
They had something called the
hand cannon from the Chinese.
Why you a n?
It's won dynasty as one where
stick the little match in there.
Yeah.
And it was like they
held it in front of them.
It's like a two foot long tube.
And that was a,
that was 1271.
Clever,
clever.
The Chinese man,
that's insane.
The Chinese came up with a gun and 12,
seven.
Wow.
They were smart as fuck.
And those days when Europe
was not something within that,
listen to this,
the earliest depiction of gunpowder,
weapon of a gunpowder weapon
as the illustration of a fire.
Lance on a mid 10th century Silk Banner.
So 9,000.
That's insane.
And it was a,
uh,
somehow I guess at the end of it it was
like a lance and at the end of it it had
gunpowder and fucking did
something and shot something out.
How proud would you be the first person
that like went to their king or whatever
and was like,
dude,
you,
you want to look at this?
I'm about to get all the bitches,
dude,
I just flipped the script
through the game on its head.
Motherfucka I was going to ask you,
do you have any questions
about the Goswami?
Oh yeah.
Well,
you're a physicist.
Yes.
Now I feel good.
Yeah.
Technically less legit than him.
Well he's,
he's written books and
shit and then your money.
He did a very nice guy.
That guy,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Interesting cat.
Um,
no I didn't,
I didn't have,
um,
uh,
any,
any questions per se.
But one thing that I'm actually,
you were the first guy to educate me on
was the observer effect being bullshit.
You know,
that's something that like Dr Quantum
and all these guys like make a big deal
that when you look up
double slit experiment,
that's the first one.
Yeah.
It comes up and it's always
been that way with the doctor,
Colleen,
that to people so they know what I'm
talking about because that I have said so
many people tweet me that dude,
do that,
check this out.
It's amazing.
It's dog to quantum to the
whole double slit experiment.
Yeah.
It's really the act of measuring it.
The changes it,
yeah.
Yeah.
It will.
I mean,
because what does it mean
measure something?
Uh,
like say you're measuring
the position of something,
then you've got to hit
it with light and then
get a lot of folks who don't even know
what the fuck we're talking about.
We're talking about Subatomic,
um,
observing,
uh,
in a subatomic conditions.
Yeah,
yeah.
Just very,
very,
very tiny things that technically
you can't see in any other sense.
But,
but you,
you hit it with light and then
the light comes back and you know,
approximately where it was,
uh,
because it's,
there's actually vertical virtual
particles and other southern stuff.
You can kind of think of it as,
as a,
as a little wave function.
So there's an uncertainty when
you hit it and it comes back and,
but when you're not hitting it,
it exists in a,
in a slightly larger wave function
is not exactly a particle.
It stretches out a little bit.
It's as nothing interacts with it,
the uncertainty grows to a certain limit.
So it's got some elbow
room where it could be.
And uh,
so the double slit experiment is from
when we were trying to figure out if
things were waves or particles.
And like some people
thought light was a wave,
some people thought it was a particle
in a wave being something that grows
outward and it,
and it spreads.
Like,
like when you dip your finger in water
and the little circles spread out.
That's basically what
we thought light did.
And we had really good reason
to believe that like uh,
if I,
if I shone some light at your laptop,
there would actually be light on you.
But like in like white
spreads around corners too.
So it actually does kind of act
like a wave to some certain extent.
So if you put,
so if you have,
and just imagine water,
if you have some sort of source like
behind a wall with the little slit in it
and the sources is causing these waves,
the waves go to the water and then at
that little slit the waves come out of
there and they spread also.
And then if you have two slits then,
then you know,
when you,
like when you put two
fingers in the water,
they were kind of little lines that come
off of the two circles where the two
circles interact in certain ways.
Yeah.
You see these little,
these little patterns and uh,
uh,
so we saw,
you can see those,
uh,
wow.
I totally lost my train of thought.
But uh,
so you,
so you don't,
so they,
they,
the water goes through both slits.
The wave goes through both slits and you
get this interference that you can see
on the other way on the other side.
And if you shoot a particle through,
these are at the sleds and it bounces
through one and then it comes out and it
hits a spot and like
shooting bullets through it,
they're going to go to
a very specific area.
But,
uh,
so you would think that was what
that would be what a electrons do.
Uh,
or any other particle really.
But it's not,
they,
they do waves too.
And if you slow it down.
So like with light,
we were treating these
light beams like waves,
but if you slow down the light
beam so much that only one part,
only one little bit of light
is going through at a time,
it still looks like it interferes.
It still creates an interference pattern.
If you do that with electrons,
it interferes and it still
creates an interference pattern.
So you don't know which,
which slit it's going through,
but you know there's only one of them.
So you say,
well,
how could this be?
So you set up the experiment
to try to met her,
which slit it comes out of.
And to do that you have a little,
a little beam of light watching one of
the slits waiting for it to come through
or to not come through.
But when that light gets there,
what used to be the wave collapses down
to the particle and then it acts like a
particle.
And so it's not,
it's not that we don't know
which slid it's going through.
It's that it is going through both when,
when we're not interacting with it.
So long as they're left
to their own devices,
they are going through even particles
like electrons are going through both
slits at the same time.
But if you're measuring it,
if you're hitting it with light then
then they act like particles and,
and uh,
why is that?
Well that's not what I said too,
by the way when he was talking about that.
Like what about the accuracy of
the laser that you shooting on?
He's like a hundred percent accurate.
Isn't that what you're talking about?
No,
no,
no.
That was the measurement of Adam.
Things moving like inanimate objects
that there's a constant movement in
everything he was talking about,
you know,
millions of an inch shares.
Yeah.
Everything has it's own little.
Uh,
yeah.
And you were talking about accuracy of
the measurement of that being the issue
now where he's talking about the,
the uh,
observation of subatomic
particles and wave experiments.
So,
so the,
the,
the two interacting with each other.
The measurement,
interacting with the particle
changes the behavior of the particle.
Uh,
um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Effectively.
But it's not observing
like a person's mind.
No,
you don't need to,
nobody needs to be there for,
right.
Okay.
So this is where the issue is
with this doctor quantum shit.
And for folks who don't know,
uh,
I know you got real pissed when,
what the bleep do you know,
came out and I did as well when
I found out that that ramp,
the guy is,
well there's a girl
that calls herself ramp.
So I thought it was just like,
that was her name.
She calls.
It was funny,
it was like,
I watched that documentary and I was like,
well a lot of people are
saying a lot of cool shit.
But then there's that weird chubby blonde
lady who just seems like a huckster.
I'm like,
she's seems so full of Shit.
Like all my alarms are going
off to meaning meaning,
but she's in this awesome movie
so I guess she's not full of Shit.
And then I go and look up
that ramp thought is actually
a woman who's channeling
fucking alien or something from like
5,000 years ago or some shit and she's in
the same movie with all these other people
and they don't have a problem if they
don't even know,
I don't think.
No.
Yeah,
they did do a lot of deceit
and making that movie.
Oh sure.
They didn't know.
They probably just weren't and wanted to
be interviewed on quantum mechanics and
they just so excited that people want
to talk about some people got quoted out
of context.
There are certain lens like that doctor,
he modo with the water that that detects
your feelings and shit like that.
Like yeah,
that guy has like the
message in the water.
He has a whole book on that.
That's is that quoted out of context?
No,
no.
That guy thinks that.
Yeah,
he does.
That's one of those deals.
Are you a different guy?
He Moto.
Is he full of Shit?
Yeah.
I mean I haven't gotten
anybody experiment myself.
Why don't you try to do that but see,
because,
well actually he's already explained that
you really need to mean it when you're
thinking positive or
negative thoughts as these,
as these,
as this water freeze.
So I'm,
I'm,
I,
I don't think I would be capable of doing,
but I'm fine with that if you can,
if he could replicate Vudu
if you don't believe in it,
it doesn't work for you.
Right.
But we're talking to is a good question.
Probably like what are
they even talking about?
We're talking about is there
was a guy who wrote this book,
I believe it's called
the message in the water.
And what he did was he would like
write love on like a bucket of water or
whatever the fuck it was or
label whatever the container was.
And one would be hate one,
it'd be love.
And he would think about these
different things while he,
you know,
had this water there and then when it
would freeze the ice crystals would form
completely different geometric patterns.
Ugly,
ugly,
angry,
passionate,
zoomed in.
So you know,
you don't know like I don't know if he
shipped with show like the whole thing.
No,
no,
no.
But somehow we always
manage to find a spot.
Yeah.
I probably just went to
the most evil looking ones.
It's confirmation bias
and a crystal form lunacy.
Yeah.
But I don't know what it is but,
but that guy made a whole
book about that Shit.
It's really easy to get a book published.
Yeah.
He's got to prove that
he could settle book.
Right?
Yeah.
That's it.
Just proof of people it and you know,
I mean they already have
like the alternative science
section or whatever it is.
Why doesn't that fucking guy does he,
is he tried to do that again or is he,
I think he did a,
but I mean it's even,
it's even hard to like
verify in any context.
And it is and yeah,
I mean it's hard to do but you would
think you would think you would be able to
develop other experiments where your
mind could like just automatically
influenced and he,
he's been doing this for
years but he doesn't,
as far as I know,
talk about the mechanism of it.
Like how does it work?
Like what's happening?
Like that's the one thing about
the mind because it's not,
it can't be quantum mechanics
because his mind doesn't,
what's freezing it to the
fucking temperature that's
freezing it and he's not
bugging it out.
I like,
and if he was bothering the water at any
point you would be able to detect that
and the vibration or the
heat or something else.
And you'd be able to find other real
parts other than just a fucking picture.
I you would be able to posit some
sort of mechanism behind the behavior.
And that's what a lot of these guys,
they never tell you what it is.
Measurable that that is good.
Like what's like how do they get their
evidence up to par with actual science?
Like they don't cause they,
they personally don't have that,
that criteria of evidence.
They're fine with look at the
picture and oh it must be true.
And they just keep doing it.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a lot of that going on these days.
Like,
um,
when quantum physics sort
of came into the mainstream,
I mean I guess,
you know,
fine one was talking about it during the,
during the fifties and sixties,
right?
Oh well quantum mechanics
started at the beginning of it,
of the 19 hundreds.
But I mean like him in Pablo popular
culture and pop filing or I don't know
about that,
the first people to sort
of make it a mainstream.
Although I don't know how
mainstream he was at the time,
but he was definitely one of
the ones talking about in those,
in those days because he was
definitely at the forefront of it.
Right.
My point was that today though,
something seems to have
happened over the past,
like say 10,
15 years where people are like looking
for like more mystical answers for shit.
Well,
it's got a queue in it.
And I think that helps a
lot because I think if we,
yeah,
I think if we called it discreet physics,
which is what it is,
it like people think quantum,
it means waves and it means uncertainty
and it means fit whatever bullshit you
want in,
in the cracks of this mysterious physics.
But it really just means
that things come in chunks,
like they're not just waves that
like even waves are like pinched.
You would think of them
as pinched at the end.
So they're very well defined.
Like waves are very,
very well defined.
Like exactly,
precisely described.
Even like we talked about probabilities.
It's got a probability of
being here or being there,
but it's got an exact probability
of being here or being there.
The probability wave is
exact the but the problem,
but it's a probability.
So we think can just,
so they think they can just fit
whatever the fuck they want to.
But if you call it a discreet physics,
nobody would really care and nobody
would be interested because it,
they wouldn't.
It's awesome when it's defined.
The the things that we do know
about it or so mysterious.
There's so many quotes about from people,
you know,
if you think you understand
quantum mechanics,
you don't,
nobody understands,
nobody understands quantum mechanics.
And it's kind of a term because you
can't develop an intuition for it
whatsoever.
Like the only reason we
understand it is the math,
right?
And the only way you could ever build an
intuition from it is understanding the
math because it,
it's,
it's the most Matt,
like nobody wanted it to
be true in the beginning,
you know,
quantum physics because
it's so fucking weird.
But we kept stumbling on all these
different pieces of mathematics,
all these different parts
of these languages that were
being developed that kept
giving us the right answers
and kept saying like you would,
they would come up with some,
some sort of model and
mathematics and they would say,
Oh hey,
that looks a little bit like
this thing we see sometimes.
And then it turns out to be true.
And then it tells us all these
other things when we got all well,
that's bullshit.
That couldn't be there.
And it is because our
intuition just sucks at it.
But the math is his exact,
the math has precise,
like it's not mysterious in that sense.
Like what?
Yeah,
there's no,
it's hard to say why.
Like you can't ask why.
That's not the question there.
There's,
there are certain people
that they are the quote,
it gets attributed to a lot of people,
but it's shut up and calculate is the
answer to why does it work that way?
How does it work that way?
Just shut up and do the math cause
you're not gonna think it through
very,
what is it though that led to this whole,
what the bleep do we know
sort of ideology behind it.
Like it sort of got twisted into the
secret and to this idea that you're
controlling the world with
your mind and that these uh,
these possibilities and probabilities are
all defined and described in the human
imagination.
And that's,
you know,
and that's where they wanted to come up
with something like this doctor quantum
thing,
server changes the experiment.
Like,
I don't know that the origin of it,
but I mean,
you know,
there's always been ideas about,
about,
uh,
the mind having control over,
over reality and things like that.
And I think the observer effect and
words like uncertainty and quantum and
everything else gave them a chance
because it's not like they understand it
either for the most part,
like Goswami does,
but 99% of the people you hear talk about
it don't understand it at all either.
But so the people they're explaining it
to definitely don't fucking understand
it.
So it gives them,
it gives them credibility
that that isn't theirs.
But it,
it's,
it's science,
it's scientific and it's new
and all this other shit it,
and since I don't know what it means,
but I can insert certain of my
beliefs within things and then say,
oh yeah,
because it's quantum and then nobody,
nobody can call your
bullshit because nobody,
it that
when Deepak Chopra,
um,
did you ever see that there was a
talk where Depok show Oprah was a,
there was a guy in the
audience who writing a book
with Stephen Hawkings and he
start in the,
ask them to define what he meant.
He's like quantum in the quantum with
quantum knowledge in quantum consciousness
being non local and quantum.
And he goes,
well,
I understand those words that you said.
I don't really know what you're saying.
Thank you in that order.
It makes no sense.
But that's a,
that's a weird trickery thing where people
use that word quantum and they start
tossing it around,
you know,
that it,
it,
it almost allows for
it 89% of the people listening to it and
not going to know what the fuck you're
saying.
So people just allow you to say it.
Yeah.
Quantum physics seems like it makes
all of classical physics make no sense.
Right.
So that's a perfect place
to put your pet theory.
It's a place that is already
eliminated the legitimacy of,
of all of we what we understand now.
Like it's a window of
opportunity for them.
Yeah.
And there's a certain arrogance to that.
Oh that woundedness,
you know,
which always that wound blueness always
wants to debunk science that will wound
it screamed the mainstream
is always wrong.
It's time for a change.
Well and I could see what they're saying
is that science cannot define a lot of
the human existence.
That's that is,
is very real intangible like love and
emotions and experiences and you know,
but we are getting there getting close.
Right?
Yeah.
Getting real good at that.
But their idea of,
you know,
science is being this,
this rigid,
you know,
non understanding
numerical sort of approach,
which it can be whenever anyone's
in any sort of a position of power,
whether a new scientific formula comes
by the way of some people who either
haven't done the research you've done
to describe it and they're skeptical lie
occasionally they make up data.
Sure.
Remember when a cold fusion,
when everyone's was a hot on the cold
fusion trail and people were claiming to
have,
uh,
created cold fusion.
Yeah.
There's always weird things
like that where people not sure,
but at the end of the day,
science is responsible for every single
fucking thing that's in front of you.
The flaws of it come from people not from,
not from the method itself.
Yeah.
That's cause that's the funny thing.
Whenever,
whenever something like
that gets overturned,
like when somebody gets in,
science gets corrected or found
out that they were making,
making up data or doing,
doing shady shit or they were
mistaken or anything like that.
It's never these people complaining about
mainstream science that correct them.
It's always other scientists.
Yeah.
Because that it's a self correcting thing.
It's it as so long as you no presumption
except that if you keep asking the
universe it will give you the answer.
But that's
dia behind science is brilliant.
The idea behind the,
the understanding of the world
due to measurement is perfect.
The real problem is the fucking humans
measuring it and the ego and all the
other nonsense that comes
along with being a person.
And that's where people tend to get upset.
And that's where,
you know,
the quantum Wu talk sorta like fills the
gap by the people that are disenchanted
disillusioned by the system,
the rigid system that they see not being
able to understand psychics are Tarot
card reading astrology.
Yeah,
exactly.
And it's like,
you know,
astrology has been around for thousands
of years and they never told us anything
about those stars
and the Ching,
the Chinese method of divination.
How long has that been
around and how much,
you know,
I've always wondered about that.
You know,
the,
the idea that there's been methods
of divination that people have used
throughout history and one theory
is that in order to bypass the,
the human ego and our limited grasp on
the understanding of the world that we
live in,
there's a certain amount of knowledge
that can be pulled out of any sort of a
situation by a method of divination.
And that what you're really doing by
this method of divination is allowing the
universe to give you data.
I think because I mean most of our brain
isn't part of the conscious part but,
but it's still thinking like
nobody really considers that.
But like your subconscious
mind is thinking all the
time and communicating all
the time.
It might be doing,
it might be juggling certain thoughts
for like weeks and then gives it to you
fully fleshed out and you're like,
oh,
I just had a brilliant idea.
Right?
The rest of your brain
has been thinking about.
So,
and it's take interpreting and taking
in a lot of information and a lot of
different ways that it's not telling
you about because you don't need to know
about it.
So in certain senses,
our intuition can become extremely useful.
Like especially with dealing with people,
like there's all sorts of stuff going
on with other people's faces and body
language is that you don't have to
know about to pick up on and then go,
that guy's a creep and I don't know why.
It's because other parts of your
brain are doing this thinking for you.
Yeah.
That is the weirdest thing.
When someone's being shifty and you,
if you tried to explain,
explain subtle shiftiness to someone,
you know when you're talking to
somebody like get the fuck no,
you can't get in my car.
That weird feeling where you just felt
like someone's just fucking shifting,
but try writing down on paper and try it.
What tools on their pupils
dilating their cores swelling up?
Like,
I don't know,
just the weird social scenarios that
you're getting from the one that,
the tension from the communication where
you know that they're trying to keep it
together or would they
or they might hit you.
You know that weird you're had been
around someone you think is going to hit
you.
There's that weird charge in the air,
like a,
you might hit me right now,
like I,
I feel some weird shit going on here.
Try describing that.
Yes.
I mean,
so,
so I think when it comes to like,
like certain things about
like a shaman type characters,
like dealing with people or community
issues or even to some extent like nature,
like maybe their body is picking up on
the fact that like 20 years ago there was
a flood for a really regular reason and
now it's coming up again or something
like that.
Like they could have an intuition
that they don't know about,
but they've been working on it.
They've been trying to develop
their intuition so much.
Like that's what they do.
So they keep working these parts of their
brain until they are actually good at
something.
They have no idea what they're doing.
Huh.
Just like anything else,
they keep working it and
keep trying to be intuitive,
like cold reading and stuff like that.
Like you keep doing it and
you keep getting good at it.
And whether or not you
even know that that light,
you're,
you know,
you're manipulating these people around
you telling them about their dead
relatives or anything
and you get good at it.
And it's not because you're getting a
stronger intuition with dead people.
It's because you're getting
stronger intuition with them,
whether or not you're actually
doing it deliberately.
Yeah.
I,
I think that any person who's a huckster,
if you have been deceiving people for,
you know,
x amount of years and pulling shit
out of your ass or x amount of years,
you're going to get good at it.
Just like anything else,
you probably do get sort of an
idea of like your grandmother,
Mrs You,
my grandma died last year.
Yeah.
And they're,
you know,
there are people that have prime.
They're already,
they're thinking about their dead.
What always fascinates me,
I've had a friend that,
uh,
he's,
he's gone to psychics
before and he's like,
dude,
you wouldn't believe man,
she knew everything about me.
Match,
just totally legit.
Starts telling me about
the psychic and I go,
did she know anything
that you didn't know?
He goes,
no,
like a little fucking good.
As she's
telling you,
she's telling you some shit you already
knew about your all family perfect.
He just,
he just paid to have someone
remind you of your memories.
So the dumbest things ever size that wolf.
Oh my God.
Wilson one shot.
It's crazy.
It was fucking scary,
man.
Can we just killed them off.
We killed them off in
America for the longest time,
but thankfully now because
of animal activists,
they've reintroduced the wolf,
they're decimating deer
populations throughout the metro.
That desire for control,
it's really strong in us.
Like even even,
you know,
progressive people,
kind people.
It's that,
that desire to control.
Cause I mean as Kay,
like they think nature is like balanced.
Like people talk about balance in nature
like that is ever fucking existed.
Nature has been a struggle for
three and a half billion years.
That's why it is as crazy and weird as
it is now because things keep competing
for space,
for resources,
for everything else.
If I eat a steak,
you can't eat that state.
Yeah.
And that's a fucking
problem for you.
Yeah.
And again,
you know,
as we were talking about before this,
this balance,
it's a natural cycle and it's probably
natural that we want to interrupt the
balance by bringing back the mammoth.
You know that's probably
all some natural are weird.
Again,
I think we should,
I think we should totally take control.
Like not for the same reason
like progressive's too,
but I just,
I think we should.
Scientific reasons and interest
reasons like let's just it a cork,
let's just make it a cool,
cool world.
When we're in,
we're in control so you know,
you start switching out trees,
maybe maybe start some
genetically modified trees
that leak MDM a or something
Dunkin at the idea this planet,
like an experiment,
like the experiment that it is.
Dunkin of the idea of
engineering a psychedelic virus
like a even bola and just
like starts forming acid Ebola
instead of killing people.
Just fucking gives everyone to acid trips.
That sounds more damaging
than a Zombie apocalypse.
Well it would definitely cut back.
A lot of the work would be
a lot of shit done done.
But at this point in time,
man,
think about all the fucking
things that you can buy right now.
How many of the things that you can buy,
do we actually need or how many of them
will be buying just because they're new?
I mean if there are things right,
the way the world is right now,
this very moment today on March,
what is it?
The 19th March 19th,
2013 the way things are today,
if we all agree that no one would innovate
and create anything new for one whole
year and for that next year we work
entirely on getting our shit together.
I have beautiful,
it would be amazing.
Why do they keep putting
out cars every year?
So many fucking cars.
It's pretty good.
Yeah.
They're super great
right now are pretty bad.
They really long time and I like new cars.
Don't get me wrong.
I like the idea of the new technology
of like the the innovation.
I like the new stereo
systems and their navigation.
I love all that stuff,
but if we only have the cars that we
have made already for the next 10 years,
we would be fine.
We'd totally be fine.
But then we never,
we never look at a cell phone and go,
okay,
we're good.
We got this,
I was thrilled and I still am to love it.
It's still a galaxy two goddamn
fucking like seven years.
And then that pitch died on me.
I was extremely sad because
of economic reasons.
If you are some multimillionaire,
you would have some dope ass crazy phone.
Don't you shake your head at me.
You son of a bitch.
I don't like new stuff too.
Would order it on Amazon
in the middle of the night.
I got my room,
I got books and like my laptop tissues.
That's what you got a lot of tissues.
No Lube Dry Jack.
That's like,
that's how a man does it.
I would say I sound all those Weirdos,
lube it up their deck and
clean up all that preparing.
I don't want to,
I don't want to clean it up at all.
Mining waste of fucking time.
Um,
I know you're skeptical,
uh,
when it comes to why a lot of things
that haven't been proven by science,
but what do you this subjects from
coming up and over and over again,
the idea of um,
remote viewing.
Do you think that's all horse shit?
Have you looked into that at all?
I,
I'm not as much as I
suppose I should cause it,
it gets in that like if I
look at every club fuckery,
yeah.
I would rather look at things
that somebody knows it's true.
You know,
like,
cause that reveals more.
But I,
I think,
I think like the idea of say you being
in a room and there's somebody at the
doorway and sometimes you notice that,
I think that sounds reasonable.
You know,
that person's disturbing the air.
They're making noise.
Even if you can't quite hear it.
Like they're,
they're affecting it.
But here's what they should do.
If they think remote
viewing is a real thing,
they,
they should try to figure out,
like I said earlier,
the mechanism for it.
Like if you can do remote viewing,
can you do it through glass?
Can you do it through?
It would,
can you do it through metal,
right.
Does it work differently
under these circumstances?
Why does it work differently
in these circumstances?
Do the people know each other?
Do they not know each other?
Did they have like,
there are so many questions you could ask
and every time you ask a question that
you can answer,
you refine your understanding
of what is actually happening.
So they should be doing that
[inaudible] I no not right,
but maybe they don't want,
so it doesn't make any sense.
Why would they not want
people to know the results?
I guess there's no profit in
proving that you can remote view.
Yeah.
And it's not necessarily profit.
Like I'm sure there's
a lot of people that,
that belief in what they're doing,
but I think a lot of times they have a,
a much lower threshold for evidence then
then the scientific community would ask
of them.
Like,
you know,
like we did two experiments with some
guy sitting in a room and he noticed the
guy who was sitting in
another room 60% of the time.
Like that's slightly peculiar,
but there's like there,
there's these,
the law of rare events,
which is like a,
a way of statistically analyzing data.
And like just by the nature of statistics,
you would expect uncommon
things to happen.
Like somewhat regularly light,
like say with like
basketball making shots.
Like you would expect that sometimes
somebody makes 10 shots in a row or with a
coin toss,
you would expect that sometimes,
uh,
you would get 10 heads in a row.
It would be weird if you didn't
like that would be inexplicably,
if you never got like 10 heads
in a row after you flipped,
flipped a coin and say a thousand times
or something like that would be the
weird thing.
So when they do really small tests,
like,
like say with just a few
people you don't know,
like if that was an an anomaly,
if it was a curiosity,
if it was an actual effect,
you don't know until you keep getting
more and more and more and more data.
And then you refine it.
The Higgs Boson,
they did like billions,
hundreds of billions,
maybe more uh,
experiments hitting,
hitting proton beams together to,
to get the,
to get the energy of the Boson out.
How many they do.
I think they do like
billions a day or something.
I can't really remember.
They do what?
Fucking lot billions of impacts a day.
Shit,
I don't actually remember but
they have over time at least done.
Huh?
Like hundreds of billions.
They do a lot because I mean it's not,
it doesn't take a whole lot.
Once you've got the whole setup
going and you just accelerate them,
smash them together,
data,
all records and then you load up another,
another round of Proton beams or whatever
it is and you keep doing it over and
over and over.
And because the Higgs is supposed
to be really hard to find B,
it was,
and it was only supposed to happen.
It was a very rare event just by
the nature of the quantum mechanics.
Like they smash all these things together
and sometimes you smashed two protons
together and you get these certain types
of Bose ons and a Neutrino or sometimes
you smash them together and you get
a bunch of neutrinos and photon and
something else.
Like there are different
different combinations of
things you can get once you
create all that,
when to get that amount of mass or of,
of energy of charge distribution of all
these other little quantum effects span
and everything else.
When you get them in like one little area,
you get different things
popping out of it.
And popping the Higgs bows on
out was very rare effect that
Boson is one fascinating
thing that they discovered.
Another fascinating thing
was that cork gluon plasma.
That's a,
that's some intense shit man.
What does it like some
insane amount of weight,
like a sugar cube?
Have you dropped it?
It would fall straight to
the center of the earth.
Like it's fucking trillions of tons.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
I don't know specifically about it.
I mean,
so court,
okay.
So Adam's are made up of electrons on
the outside and shells and then protons
and neutrons inside protons
having a positive charge,
neutrons being neutral and a,
the protons and neutrons are
not fundamental particles.
The way the,
the electron is,
the electron is appoint particle,
which I mentioned in a second,
but,
uh,
the proton and the neutron
are made up of three quarks,
each of different kinds of different
configurations of these three quirks and
they're just more fundamental particle.
And what's keeping them together is the
strong force and what the strong and the
strong force is mediated by,
by a blue ones.
In the same way that,
like we talked about photons and the
electromagnetic field and light is the
interaction isn't electromatic
magnetic interaction.
Photons are,
are,
are the mediator of electric fields and
far down,
can they get where they're going
to actually still see these things?
Like how small does it get
before you're just guessing?
Hmm.
Well,
I mean his drink theory is guessing,
right?
Well,
a string theories.
Yeah.
String theories.
Guessing.
But,
uh,
I mean like until then,
like that's several orders of magnitude
lower than the subatomic particles.
Like electrons for now as it is,
uh,
they seem to be point particles,
which means there are
zero dimensional there.
They don't have a size,
they don't have a,
a depth,
they don't have a surface at all.
That shit's ridiculous.
I know that's the most,
that's the lowest
measurable point of reality.
And it's up to Voodoo.
Yeah.
It's,
you should think of it as,
as an intersection of all the different
qualities that makes up and electron
like,
but it,
it,
it doesn't have a surface and we,
and even if it does have a surface,
we can't get close enough to it because
of the whole uncertainty principle with
him trying to hit it.
Like if you want to get really close,
like whites got different wavelengths,
right?
Like radio waves have a wavelength of
like meters long and then like you squeeze
them together and you get up to microwaves
and then up to visible light and then
like ultraviolet light and it's just the,
uh,
higher wavelength gives
them a higher energy.
So with like a really long wave length,
it's like having a
really long meter stick.
So if you're trying to measure,
say like the width of your
foot with a yard steak,
you're going to get a
really inaccurate answer.
So you want something smaller.
And that's the same thing
with measuring position.
You want something smaller to measure
it and that's a smaller wavelength.
But as you do that,
you get a much higher energy.
So they smash into that fucking electron
and then you're not quite sure what the
fuck happened there because it hit it.
So
basically we'll then be able to figure
things out better in the future with more
accurate measurement.
Hopefully.
Well,
I mean what we,
I mean and that's not,
not in that way.
Like we're never going to be able to,
like we can create the whole spectrum
of light gamma rays being being the most
dense.
And if you tried to put more energy
into that and to such a small area,
you'll start getting like particles.
Cause it's too,
too much energy.
I'm like their light,
it'll just turn into a particle.
So when they see an electron,
like when they can measure an electron,
what exactly do they really say?
The,
the electrical resistance
of it to the photon.
Wow.
Yes.
And so,
uh,
we know now that like virtual particles
are popping out of these things all the
time.
Like they talk about the
electric field of the electron,
but that field is chunky.
It's quantized right it,
so it's not smooth and it just doesn't
like start dense and like fade out as it
goes.
It's all these little virtual particles
that are go and they go out and then
they fall back in.
It's until something else hits the
average person who's driving in their car
right now listening to you
talk to understand what the
fuck you're even saying.
I have no idea where to start.
Yeah.
It's like that's the hardest part.
Like this is your educational background,
which trying to dense it or condense it
rather to these sort of understandable
terms where someone without a great
deal of education and it can understand
that.
Yeah.
So,
so if you think of any,
any electron and it's got this charge
and a lot of people kind of know that and
deal with static charge
and shit like that.
So it's got this field emanating from it.
And for a while we thought it
was just a really smooth field,
kind of the way you would imagine like
an aura of sorts emanating from this
thing.
But then with quantum mechanics and
then later quantum field theory,
we realized that even that is not true.
Even that's not smooth.
It's made up of this chunky super position
of of other particles that kind of
behaves like a field until you
get really detailed with it.
Right.
And so it's,
it's emanating and reabsorbing all of
these little particles all the time.
And so when you try to hit
it with another particle,
you don't know which of these particles,
which momentum or anything like
that are going to interfere with it.
And this is kind of,
we're a part of the uncertainty comes
from like you don't know when and where
these little bits are coming out of the
electron and when they're absorbing in
or where it's jumping around
and all this other shit.
So they're,
they're just being created and usually
they get reabsorbed but if something else
gets in there then they,
you start hitting back on it and
then when that light comes back,
that's the surface that we
see when we try to measure it.
So fucked up that you think is of the
nature of reality at its smallest point is
that it really is like
little crazy magical elves.
Yeah,
it's kind of a bummer.
Why is it a bummer?
So it's super embarrassing.
Like it could have been much easier,
but it's amazing.
It is amazing.
It's amazing.
It's amazing that most
things are filled with space,
empty space,
even hard things or the
majority of it is just nothing.
Yeah.
All this thinking of things is solid
is just a really good approximation for
things our size.
I'm like,
that's why we developed that.
It's just,
I mean,
because effectively it is,
but it's just an electric field.
That tour we're hitting.
It's too crazy.
Sometimes it makes me tired like this one,
just this podcast just made
me tired cause I'm like,
it's just too much.
It's just too nutty.
And this is all I think about everyday.
All me to that in um,
simulation theory simulation.
The other thing that's been bounced
around in my head all day that's a,
that James Gates Shit.
Yeah.
Superstring the James kept
correcting computer code.
Yeah.
And I certainly don't know
enough about string theory
or computer code to really comment on it.
But I think it's
interesting cause it's like,
it's not like,
like what would be the difference
between this universe in a real one?
Like would that,
would those characteristics
exist in a real one?
If we were in a fake one?
And by the way,
I'm,
I'm sure we're,
we're real
and I'm also sure it
doesn't really matter.
I'm not sure.
I don't think it matters.
I doesn't matter if it's this good.
Hm.
Doesn't matter.
I mean it is most
certainly its own universe.
Like unless there was something
that could cease it,
like I don't see any reason to not.
Thank you mean by sees it
like in the universal media.
Well then why would it have to do that
if you've curse while I was working for
Google in my leaves might get
assimilated into the program.
The,
the idea that technology
is ever increasing,
exponentially constant never going change
unless there's a natural disaster or
nuclear bombs or whatever
the fuck happens.
If that does happen it will be inevitable.
But we have,
well first we have to assume that
that is actually something that,
that somebody could do is
create a perfect simulation.
I mean we assume so,
but we haven't seen
anybody say that though.
Given all the time in the world it's
inevitable without interference.
I don't know cause I don't know.
It's like I don't,
I don't know how to make a universe.
I know we,
we could assume something but I have not.
And also besides that,
like you know,
Lauren's crafts in the
universe from nothing.
Yes.
Like those universes that just pop out
of nothing seems like they would probably
be way more common than created universes
because there's a lot of space for an
entire new universe to grow in.
But ultimately it doesn't even matter
whether it's more common as long as it
happens once you,
as long as one species that's super
intelligent and keeps going on and on
without interruption.
But natural disaster for the next
hundred thousand years and computer power
exponentially increases to the point
where video games become virtual reality
versions.
Like,
like for all we know,
I mean this universe is extremely large.
Took a lot of energy.
It's infinite.
Yeah.
It's like,
and fractal meaning infinite universes.
Wow.
Well,
okay.
I,
I don't think we really,
we really know that about fracking.
I mean,
they're fractal.
All the natural fractals are limited
to a certain number of scales,
like the random fractals,
like the mantle,
but mental broad set and the
Julia sets and stuff like that.
Those are infinite.
But we've never seen an
infinite fractal in nature.
We see stuff like ferns,
which makes sense on the leaf.
The branch.
Yeah.
We,
we,
we see it in certain places,
but there's always a
top and a bottom to it.
I get it never goes.
It's never infinite scales.
Right.
It,
so,
but the idea of the
universe being fractal,
isn't it?
That the black holes are
gateways to another universe.
Each black hole contains
hundreds of billions of galaxies,
each with a black hole inside of them
with hundreds of billions of galaxies
inside of it.
And since that may not be necessarily
infinite but in measurable.
Gotcha.
Well,
I mean,
black holes do have a finite energy,
right?
They do it,
it,
it defines their,
their side,
maybe 1% of the mass of
the galaxy that exists.
Yeah.
Super massive black holes.
So,
so it is defined.
So maybe like if there's other
universes inside a black hole,
like
the universe itself inside the black
home may be defined by the size of the
black hole.
Yeah.
But it's like we have all these
black holes in our universe,
right?
So if our universe was
inside a black hole,
it would have to contain all the
energy of all those black holes also,
unless it's just popped out of nothing.
And then
if it's popping out of nothing,
then we don't need to
be inside a black hole.
We don't need to be inside.
Anything inside may be a
completely arbitrary concept.
Yeah,
it may be.
it's a part of like these
are doorways and I mean like,
like the whole other things that
indicate that maybe our universes is just
generated out of nothing is the fact
that if you take all the energy and
there's,
there's positive energy of all the
stuff and there's negative energy from,
from relationships between gravitation
and like the location of things.
If you add it all up,
it seems to add up to zero,
which is say that our universe has
a net total energy content of zero,
which is kind of what you would expect
for something that came from nothing.
Nothing at all.
Rather than,
than being generated by a computer
program or anything like that.
The wackiest theory of
the world has ever known.
Forget about Jesus and Moses and Thor.
How about the fact that the
fucking scientific community,
the communities,
number one theory on the creation of
the universe is the Big Bang theory?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It,
I mean,
but it's,
it's where all the evidence pointed.
Yeah.
Like that's the thing,
like we couldn't make it up.
It's just seems to be like,
it's not,
it's not scientist fault.
That's so insane.
The idea that the universe was smaller
than literally the head of a pin.
The entire universe,
infinitely dense,
smaller the head of a pin and go.
Yeah.
I mean technically we're still
pretty uncertain about that first,
like second or two,
right.
Most of the universe we,
we understand pretty well up until
you get to like that first second.
But isn't it funny that people like,
Oh,
you really believe Jesus
came back from the dead?
That so unlikely.
Well,
is it,
is it any more unlikely than the whole
fucking universe existing out of a tiny
things smaller than the head of a pin,
which explodes for no apparent reason.
No University?
Well,
we know at least one universe exists.
We don't know at least one person
that's come back from the dead.
That's true.
Yeah.
You gotta go where the evidence hasn't
come right from the dead and we know the
billions of people have lived and died
and none of them have told us about her
plan like,
well,
you don't know,
man.
I saw this Morgan back from the dead
and then he took his body to heaven.
He took the evidence to have an like an
ass Holsten you people are not ready for
him yet.
We've got to wait till we get our
shit together and they'll come back.
Great.
If like God didn't realize that people
were too dumb to get the message.
2000 years ago,
he was like,
oh my God.
These people are fucking idiots.
They've been worshiping cows for while.
I think if God really wanted
us to get the message,
she would probably tell us all the time
back when people didn't have phones.
Yeah,
it's either that or he's a gigantic
Dick is going to punish you for all of
eternity based on some hearsay you're
going to get from people who fuck kids.
If there's self-aware organisms in the
universe and you made the and you give a
shit about anything they do.
Yeah.
Just bring it up.
Don't leave them with a book that's been
translated three different times and
three of them different fucking languages
that are thousands of years old.
Microsoft updates like every four years.
If God really was that guy like,
man,
what?
How bad would that suck if we really
were under the the complete power of some
Dick of
3000 years ago I came down,
I gave you a Zombie.
He came back to life.
You don't pay attention.
Fuck you.
Then burn in hell.
What about the baby's awesome?
He has a very,
very low criteria.
Maybe he has done,
you don't even know.
The most mind blowing thing that I ever
heard when in relationship or in that
relates to the size of
the universe was on that.
Even watch that Morgan
Freeman show through the,
through the worm hole or whatever it is,
really shit.
They had these scientists that
were trying to explain infinite.
They're trying to explain the the
infinite nature of the universe.
And he said that infinite is so big
and this is so hard to understand.
But what infinite means is that not
only is there an exact version of earth
somewhere but the exact series of
events exactly as they've happened here,
happened there like there are so many
earths that would be so many environments
that are exactly like ours because you're
dealing literally with something that
has no end.
So in the insanely vast
distance of forever literally.
And we could still say that there are
certain things that wouldn't be like there
wouldn't be yes and maybe no,
maybe everything would happen exactly
as it did on this in this earth.
But right next door
there's a fucking earth,
you know a couple of trillion light years
away that everything happened up until
a certain point.
And then you got ahold of some Parkinson's
disease medication that turned you
into a gay sex and gambling addicts and
your life went off the fucking rails.
Things like that.
But like,
there wouldn't be a universe where you
and I are having this conversation except
Brian is a pink hippo like mine because
the laws of the universe that made us
don't include pink hippos.
Hippo produced can talk,
he's all bummed out.
He wanted to be a pink
hippo is pink hippo.
That's why they wanted to be a dolphin.
A dolphin.
Oh,
you want to be in a dolphin?
But no,
uh,
there was this conversation on,
on the board recently where
I brought up the thing about,
uh,
if you had a thousand
monkeys on typewriters,
eventually they would write the works of
Shakespeare given an infinite number of
time or amount of time.
I think that's horse shit.
But it is true because an
infant in a number of time.
Yeah,
because if you had like it,
let's just take out the monkeys and say,
you have one computer program.
You imagine that a monkey really did,
right?
Like Romeo and Juliet.
You just left this monkey in a
fucking room of the Thai baht.
And most of it was dog shit.
Most of them just a Dcsi.
Why,
why?
But one day that monkey just got it right
and his little fucking eyes rolled in
the back of his head like a slot
machine and he starts typing.
It just can't even right at the end of
midsummer night's dream car about Romeo.
I mean,
the question is,
you know,
like say you're randomly
selecting characters,
like each character is randomly selected
and you do this for an infinite string
of characters,
then not only would you get,
uh,
the entire works of Shakespeare,
but you would get an
infinite number of times.
You would get it backwards
an infinite number of times.
You would get every
chapter in every order,
an infinite number of times you would
get everything that's ever been written
and every single order that you could
ever think to put it in an infinite number
of times by much sweat,
infinite.
That monkeys,
well,
he's on a typewriter.
I would use chimps,
but yeah,
they're,
they wouldn't hurt their little fingers.
Monkeys,
they're little tiny hands.
Yeah,
man,
that's the word.
Yeah.
Even that it doesn't even begin to
describe it and that that word is a real
problem word.
We don't,
we really,
that doesn't register with me.
When I say infinite,
I might just like space.
It's like until I can think
about it and then it keeps going.
I mean even just like when you see
those videos of like they send a probe,
like an artificial probe like to show
you what it looks like when they leave
earth and then it sees the moon and it
sees the other outer planets and then it
sees,
you know,
the,
the galaxy from a distance.
Then it keeps going and going.
That doesn't work.
It doesn't get in there.
I mean that they're,
they're so fucking far away when you
have to start thinking about the speed of
light,
like the fact that the sun is
like eight light minutes away.
Maurice is like 30 light minutes away.
Pluto is like 18 hours
away in terms of lights.
We'll,
Dr Greer's going to let us know,
goodness,
how big the universe is when reveals
what the aliens have been telling him and
uh,
which you would think he would
know so much that he actually,
he meditated and contacted them.
That's the way to do it.
You know,
you really should have asked
him some of their new science.
Like surely they know some
things that scientists don't.
That would really help us long.
Well they know how to come here.
Well they're really good us.
We knew how to go there.
Do you really want to
go there though dude?
Cause what if you get stuck?
I don't know.
Maybe that's why they're here.
Cause it fucking sucks.
Could be they don't have
gazelles or anything there.
Yeah,
they probably just all of them,
they've,
they've bred themselves to the point with
a uniform that either they're all just
great things with a big
fucking stupid heads.
No muscles.
Do you ever say years ago they had a,
that thing about if you
distorted a person's face and
the way that a baby's fit,
what happened to
it?
Because you use in a fucking shitty
Samsung device instead of a God damn apple
iPad.
No,
I'm using the iPad but the,
the uh,
uh,
the way the babies visual system,
it's like inaccurate.
Like it's weak in various areas.
And if you do that to
an image of a person,
you get something like
it kind of bends outward.
So it kind of seems like
they have a larger head,
their eyes get much bigger because
they're very prominent in that part of the
brain that recognizes faces.
Hmm.
And A and it gets a little colorless
and they kind of look like aliens.
That was an assumption.
That was years ago.
I Dunno if they follow it up.
Well that's interesting.
So the images that we have from our
early childhood might sort of be the
archetype.
Some reason for angels and aliens and
Demons and all these other make believe
things that people keep thinking they're
interacting with throughout history.
Like there's,
there's some sort of reason for that.
What do you think it is neurologically?
Do you think it also the extrapolation,
like the idea that you're,
your body knows where it's going
and that that's the future.
Like if we look at chimps,
lower primates,
whatever it is,
and then we look at human
beings and following the trend.
If you look at that,
that is the trend.
I mean we are the the ape man.
Maybe you know,
it's the trend.
Like we're,
I think,
I think that would be great if we start
going in space and we lose all our
muscle mass in our,
in our hair and our
guys are dicks to dude.
They have no decks.
Dude.
Imagine the processing power
of their internal pornography.
Yeah.
I think it just touch you on your nose
and you'd come in your pants but you
wouldn't even have pants.
God,
that's the best x man ever.
Who would make you come with rob banks
just to make sure that x man showed up?
Yeah.
If you look at a gorilla and you look
at a person and you look at an alien,
we're closer to the alien yard from,
from man.
We aren't we closer to the look of an
a gray alien than we are to a gorilla.
Pretty seamless.
Others that shaved or that
hairless hairless chimp
that looked quite a bit like
a person.
Yeah.
That thing would work.
Brock Lesnar
[inaudible] if you took
away the sword Tattoo.
Yeah.
Those.
Look,
why didn't,
I would love to see
that chimp with tattoos.
Even just like fake tattoos.
Yeah,
tribal dollies.
Barbed wire and shit.
How scary would it be if you had
a Mike Tyson Tattoo on his face
shape?
What those Mike Tyson tribals.
That'd be terrible.
Oh,
I'm scare the fuck out of it.
Wasn't there a story about Mike
Tyson went and fight attempt?
I'm sure he probably back in early,
early years,
he was like offering like 10,000 the
only way it would work as if they,
they closed the mouth of the champ and
they didn't teach them how to fight.
Fuck that.
All you'd have to do is the chimp.
All we'd have to do is
get ahold of you though.
The thing is get ahold of me.
Anybody?
I don't know about Mike,
I don't know Tyson,
but can they take a punch like
I know they can take some abuse,
but has it,
has any,
has any chimp just like really fucking
right hooked and other champion
that job,
do they have that button
that just puts them out?
What's a good question.
And also the,
the,
the size of their head and
bone structure and everything,
that kind of damage that Tyson can do,
like as they're closing
the distance on you.
If Tyson on corks with like a right
left combination palm home straight,
right ham,
power left hook behind it,
boom.
Right to the chimps dome.
Can a chimp take it?
I wonder if there's a little really good.
That is why we need science.
Yeah.
Needing it to answer that.
Quite take a chimp and lets
them do tee off on a chimp.
Just say let Leo a chimp.
Well that's the only way to do,
unless you want to sacrifice the man.
I don't think anybody's gonna allow
you to let a champ lose to fuck.
Cause the first thing that
chimps going to do is,
but I don't think anybody's gonna
allow you to tie up at champion,
punch it in the fucking face.
I would think that would happen.
It would be more likely to happen than
to have a cage fight with a chimp or a
boxing match with a chimp
Southeast Asian country.
It probably already did it.
Well,
I think they did that with
the rang of tanks in boxing.
But they don't really rip things right?
No.
When they give him gloves and then
about monkeys are kind of person.
He's like,
yeah,
they're not biters like humans.
I was like,
God,
chimpanzees or humans for that matter,
chimpanzees are rude.
They just go right for your tech.
Rip that off.
Rip Your feet off,
bite your fingers off.
Novas are so nice.
And we're as related to
each of them equally.
But nobos the,
they can't even have Benobos in a
fucking zoo cause it just start with the
hanging can't have them cause
they just start fucking,
they fuck everywhere and jerk
off in front of everybody.
I do think it's a good reminder though,
like when people bring up how
violent chimps are and they're like,
you know,
there our closest cousin like,
so where'd that violent?
We're also close to the,
to the do nothing but fuck all day.
Yeah.
What happened?
How'd that it's like,
it's almost like they're their bolt.
They both represent the closest living
primate to us and yet they both represent
the total opposites of the spectrums
of human behavior and almost that
particular circumstance.
I'm sure they have,
you know,
similar social structure
fight and Alpha males do.
Right.
Elphaba aren't they matriarchal though?
No.
Goes.
Yeah.
I think the uh,
the females are a charge.
That might be the issue too.
That comes up a lot.
Yeah,
I think that would definitely help.
I mean,
surprise the ones that
give birth run show,
well the only other matriarchal society
that I know of in the animal kingdom is
hyenas.
Lions too,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I thought the mail was a bitch.
He likes,
stayed home and took care of the guilty,
takes care of everything.
The males are enormous,
but it doesn't kill,
well he does occasionally,
but mostly kills like predators
and hyenas and shit like that.
But the males,
the king of the jungle and
he's the biggest motherfucker.
He's the baddest,
he protects the other lions
from encroaching mails and
things along those lines.
But Hyenas are actually matriarchal in
that the female is larger than the male.
And actually has a foe penis.
She dominates the mail.
She gets on top of them and
fucks him with her fake.
She pegged him.
Yeah.
It's huge.
If you're seeing it,
hold on,
I haven't seen puts your boner female.
Yeah,
it's like a pussy boner.
But it's bigger than a real
Boehner.
I mean,
it's enormous.
It's like an arm may female,
Hyena,
penis,
hyenas.
Huge.
It's shoe.
It's bigger than the males like this.
Yeah.
It's a bigger than the males.
Awesome.
What?
She's bigger.
And the reason why is because
the life of a heinous,
so ruthless,
the female has to be large to keep
the males from eating the babies.
So the females have to run things cause
the hyenas just live in the most nasty
world possible.
Everything is just stealing meat and
biting things and then snapping bones,
running away with chunks of carpets,
your predators and even killing them.
Have you ever seen that video
where a bunch of Hyenas Corner,
uh,
hurt female lion?
It's fucked up.
There's a,
there's a cool documentary on hyenas and
lions and it was all about how there's
a constant struggle between the
hyenas and lions and hyenas.
Well,
like circle eight.
Look at that.
Look at that fake penis.
Look at that thing.
That's a fake female
penis and it's enormous
little turd shooting in Andover.
See what it gets hard.
That debit is just walking.
I guess it doesn't come
out of Harvard Tiger,
right?
It's just like dangling off.
It's just like a horn.
It's not like [inaudible]
or something like a what?
Cloe Aka the holes that birds have and
I think some fishing and never heard of
that.
It's like they have internal genitalia.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
And that's the little hole like crocodiles
that when they sex the crocodile,
they have to stick their
finger in their cloaca.
I don't know if they call
it a Clo Waco with it.
That's how they milk them.
Well,
that's how they figure out if there's
like what's in those sex sexual
orientation.
Yeah.
That's fascinating man.
It's a god.
What's my,
to just look up her up looking at China.
China's female.
Oh,
same as down.
Don't put that.
Is that bigger than that?
He knows.
It's about the same behind.
It's aggressive.
I think that's a good way to end the show.
It's like a hitchhiker stumps.
Then they show it.
China's giant Dick Jay Dee.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
Absolutely.
This would wonderful time.
Yeah,
we confused and put bored the shit
out of people for a little bit.
Cool.
I hope most of them enjoyed it.
It's possible to that all that that
when you get into that kind of stuff,
it's been,
you've been talking about dark matter.
Ooh,
come back.
We'll do it again man.
Sounds great.
Yeah,
for sure.
All right brother.
We'll see you a in cyberspace
and in real life on occasion.
Yeah.
Tell your Mama I said hi to
absolutely got a cool month.
That was a little weird.
Tell your Mama I said Hi.
You still have a short,
how dare you,
son of a bitch.
Listen to this podcast and has
no relation whatsoever to works.
Mom,
there's none of this was real.
We're just joking around.
If you listen to this,
uh,
this podcast is to you by hover.
Uh,
if you go to,
hold on,
let me pull that up.
I'm terrible at
remembering all this stuff.
Uh,
her,
oh,
oh yeah.
Let's ask.
Throw it out there.
I saw that you were
putting that on anything.
I have someone who wants
to murder Bryan's truck.
I have a bright orange Ford
edge and it's just like,
you know,
I know in the car now it's,
I might as well do
something with the color.
And then somebody told me that you can
just put a wrap on your car and then when
you sell it,
if you,
you could just peel it off.
It's called murdering it.
You put a matte black color,
all that car,
all you're murdering,
if anyone knows how to do it or
oh,
for sure there's a lot of play,
but it's how the red band Ari Dba on,
on Twitter.
All right.
hover.com forward slash,
Rogan,
you will get 10% off your
domain name registrations.
It is a,
an excellent company that
offers a lot of cool stuff.
Very intuitive interface along with
free who is domain name registration.
Um,
excellent company.
Support them.
They support us.
hover.com forward slash.
Rogen.
We're also sponsored
by [inaudible] DOT com.
That's o.
N.
I.
T.
If you enter in the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 10%
off any and all supplements.
Um,
the,
the primal chimp,
a kettle,
kettle bells come out tomorrow.
Supposed to talk about them on it.
We can talk about it.
We launched them tomorrow.
There's only a thousand stock now though
with a thousand more are arriving in
two weeks and 5,000 in two months.
Very difficult to fucking
make these things.
But we have a kettle bells that
look like furious chimp heads.
They're,
they're dope.
You got to love them.
Why you're not gonna use it.
No,
I will.
I just want to in my living room.
I think that's a good thing to
just to put on the bookshelf.
That's good.
Seriously.
It is good for
blocking books.
Yeah.
And scaring neighbors.
All right,
your fucks.
Listen tomorrow.
Ben Hoffman from the new comedy central
show that I don't know the title
I heard.
He doesn't like weed or mushrooms
and what's he's against it.
He's again,
somebody tweeted that to me today.
I mean against it.
I don't know.
Is he going to try to
stop you from doing it?
I don't know.
He's allowed to have my own
tastes and point of view.
Brian.
Hey,
I know you're just went to
show where we running here.
If you want to follow our
buddy Jay Dee on Twitter,
it is.
What is your Tour de Niro Aristocrat?
Can't figure that out.
That's fine.
Yeah,
you can find it.
It's on my Twitter.
I follow a second and if you go back to
March 19 2013 and read my Twitter feed,
you'll see it spelled and if this is
something that you're listening to many,
many years in the future
when Twitter was just a joke,
ha ha,
they were using Twitter.
Well fuck you smarty
pants from the future.
I don't need your bull shit.
You're lucky you live in the future,
bitch.
Okay.
I'm stuck here at 2013
trying to make do with this.
All right,
let's fucking show's over.
I'm talking nonsense.
Good night everybody.
We'll see you soon.
God
bless.
Jihad.
Praise,
Odin Hollaback.
Hollaback.
Okay.